[Music]
hear you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
i believe we're live
yo what's going on
sunday sunday sunday
we are back
the lords
it is the host with the most
[Music]
launch gaming.net in a building
editorial in the building one of the
best in the business my man wayne is
good to see you buddy do a fantastic job
i don't thank you enough
[Music]
we got to figure out how to meet up in
real time at that convention or
something let me know we'll figure this
thing out lydia master what's going on
gerald mack the og the legend he'd be
holding us down he'd be letting people
know show respect
what's going on joe what's up man declan
i see you what's up lord metroid in a
building nintendo in the building ghost
fixture what's going on
thomas belotti salute bunty waguan
you're done no big up big up
you already know
raiden blade what's up what's going on
talk to me far q what's going on salute
salutes a little astral parrot king what
it do is mf time yes it's mf
trolls yo you're gonna get a warning
trojan
you don't do that here
we don't do that croc stuff here
what's up children i'm messing with you
you can do what you want like what you
like that's your feet that you
disrespected that's all you
apollo
[Music]
so yeah we're waiting for the lords to
get up in here wake up out of their beds
right the crust for me
hopefully get here from addict
and saul spoke to the king he good you
know what i'm saying oh oh oh is that
the destiny
besties what's going on from work live
from work pittsburgh in the building
salute that's my guy hustle and motivate
the g o g d v stand up
hey hey what's going on
feeling good right now i got the event
gg in the system i'm moving and shaking
i'm feeling good
you know what i'm saying but yeah we
have a good show we have a good show we
got some spicy topics as you already see
y'all had me laughing they was like i
wonder which one is king's topping you
know damn well which topic can you pick
so you already know what that is okay
what's up yeah it's gonna be a fun good
discussion with the brethren you know
what i mean so we will have some fun so
anyway i gotta go wake some people up
and see if i can figure out what the
hell going on coming
[Music]
shout out to the rocks out here
nah nah you said it right necroman
freudian slip that's how they feel like
rocks when you're
[Music]
you said it right
yo shout out to cry girl yeah y'all rep
that that that thing that y'all wear
with salute
[Music]
anyway i will talk to y'all in a minute
good to see y'all early much appreciated
on the support we'll have some fun today
[Music]
so
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social
[Music]
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing that real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but
[Applause]
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled put on the b.o dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boil you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city
[Music]
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
[Music]
could say that i'm very spoiled for them
to be your dog's thing very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on the song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
it i'm embarrassed for you i've always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with the gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rain you
just a target when i'm in the range i
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
and we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest we're advanced gg there's a lot
of things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line this is that
standard this is what we use right now
kind of our caffeine substitute and what
we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advanced gg.com use code iron lord on
the checkout this is something i use all
the time got to support advanced gg
great products if you want to get your
workout on even if you don't work out
you're just gaming you need that focus
and again the hydration line for those
who don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron law podcast peace
[Music]
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though i know
it's my destiny work to kind of who
cares if you fly if you steal a mosquito
you swear you ain't something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that you can't never still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible other than nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
it always
the chat was already like i wonder what
king's topic is i don't know what it's
for you can wonder what the heck
i said god bless
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome to the ireland podcast llc and
also the launching gaming.net episode
number 265. that's not the glory of
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day and today we've got the
last of us remake controversy
discord to xbox
ubisoft game cancellations and ps5
lawsuit astute lead brought to us by
king to discuss
so we go why do you have to carry out
that way
brought to you by the news of king david
behind
here we go
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original gaming nights in
the room here at the round table my
co-host with the coal mouse my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his old world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
of the attic show hopefully the camera
gets together you know yeah i have no
clue what's going on i i've already been
reset it's just not maybe the cam leak
needs to be hooked back up again yeah it
could be
does the cam link does the light on the
camera link is it lighting up
um no everything's fine it's just not
coming on i don't know why like i don't
even have obs so
yeah see the only time that usually
happens to me is if there's a another
camera source program
it will usually tell you if there's
another
mines don't mind would be like it it
just will open
you up
you checked it and zoom right like it's
it's not yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll
figure it out it's so good anyway what's
been going on man
uh nothing been playing this uh live a
live game and it's uh it's pretty
intense i'm not gonna lie
uh i played as the the ninja dude the
first time and he he was
he was destroyed like i was getting
murdered i was like i was thinking
myself am i trash at these games
like it was it was it was it was pretty
bad man like it was what type of game is
it it's kind of like it's from turn
based game it's the from the creator
creator of chrono trigger ff6 so exactly
that kind of game yeah big class says
switch to the avermedia one addict he
said he got your fix the avermedia one
that
that that is definitely a capture card
that's not
that's not a uh
steve go go wouldn't be iop without
camera audio issues
wow really i mean you're more than
welcome to try to
try to do how many shows a year and i
have issues
you're more welcome to do that mexican
zoidberg i like this new look fatigue
oh my gosh they're out here they camera
shaving down they going hard
i think i think a new member of the
shirttails coming out later on today
gonna be the frog shirt
big cloud offering live tech support he
said there's ava media cam link addict
lol he said there is
and if you ask these people anything
about obs i don't know eddie
hey yo yo mr order went from the chair
to the camera i'm done moving on anyway
what you've been playing man
uh
live alive that's pretty much about it
yeah um i have been i mean some other
stuff i'm playing i can't talk about
this exclusive ad exclusive we need that
we need that false button
and yeah such a deep nda they took his
camera away
you don't have a humongous statue of
something in your room addict that you
can't show i don't know what it is we
don't talk about that
he forces him to get a face tattoo when
he plays it because it recognizes
so besides that it's been just those in
the end in the nba we can't talk about
games
yeah pretty much that's about all i have
been playing a lot of fall guys like
probably an absurd amount of fog that's
kind of took my
like
the the place of my destiny mm-hmm i see
you and dj in there getting it on
yeah so we've been playing a lot of that
here recently it's uh gonna be
interesting i will be doing a review on
live alive but don't don't expect it for
at least a week because it's just games
that i've already got like 15 hours into
it and i only got like three of the
people's mission
it's like one it's like occupy traveler
where you do
multiple stories and i assume after you
do all multiple of the stories like what
will happen is like then you'll have a
story where all of them are in the story
uh so like right now i've only finished
a couple which is it's kind of crazy
because like sometimes they'll be like
throwing you
for uh for but they'll be tricking you
like you'll think the story's about one
person and it'll be like a teacher and
you teach his his
his disciples and one of them become the
main character depending on the choices
you make during your story
that's fine that's fine dj oral says
hashtag proud loves that you're playing
four guys you're four guys mean he likes
that
yeah and i'd be winning oh
oh the crowds the crowds crowd
because we ain't getting no wins with
jesus
okay
we're bringing him down
i'm terrible at that game i i gracefully
bow out and say look y'all if y'all want
to win
his jumping on the platform at the last
minute right before death
that's the greatest
i guess so
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gaming list for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastra davis the lord of
clarity and lord patron of the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
i'm chilling bro i'm swimming bullets
over here this is like 100 degrees
but uh and i hadn't i hadn't purchased
my new acs yet so we we
purchased them yes ac
multiple ac
so um but i have to it gets a whole pain
in the rear they have them installed
here so yeah still it's fanning it up so
fans the left of me advanced to the
right of me
yeah it's crazy yeah get that hot air on
you
you got to give me a second i spilled
something all over my keyboard oh no
oh now we found out the truth
[Laughter]
get what you get get it get it pop it
brother get
[Laughter]
fortunately they're nowhere close to
each other
that's
the distance attic you cover
no
so uh
sanitizing wipe sir yes sir yeah yes yes
so uh papa gabe came through again
that's a beautiful thing i'm just
rocking everything on the deck but i
actually got to finish a game wow
believe this which one skyward sword the
the the new hotness for 2022. oh what's
going on rice in the room oh you did
that rise
yo
once i threw the rise on there i
couldn't stop playing it again
damn yeah
boy you do i haven't played it in almost
10 years right so
xbox haven't got a remix none of this
stuff it's already
just uh well no well this is the pc
version
the pc version
will make you think the xbox version
looked like that but it did
hey bro
they haven't updated on the x they have
it so which they need to but
bro
right son of rome man greatest 900p
gamer of all time bro that game still
looks fantastic and then running at 60
the story the the the acting everything
about that game was top-notch and to
look at that engine 10 years later and
to for it to still be that impressive
it is something to behold the only thing
i'm telling you bro i'm telling you i
want the issue
the only thing that held that game back
a little bit was the simplicity of the
combat but and the thing about it is you
can get through i didn't i forgot about
this
you can get through the game and not
unlock unlock the majority of your
upgrades correct what i tried to do was
up unlock the majority of my execution
so i could see the hot executions or
whatever but even then you fall short
and
so i was like damn man like that was the
only thing like the balancing in terms
of that of you progressively getting
stronger didn't match the length of the
game right but playing it again man i
tell you bro it's just the simplicity of
it because this really is just counter
attack counter attack wait for the the
the qte to start or whatever but it's so
beautifully animated and and the story
is good no and the story ends super
abruptly i would
i forgot about that as well it ends and
it ends the way it should end but it
ends super abruptly which i i was i was
hoping for a little bit more exposition
at the end god bless good night
bro but it almost felt like they were
setting up a sequel that never
it probably was yeah man i mean i it
gets a lot of flack but i tell you as a
launch game from the xbox one almost 10
years ago amazing bro
it really is something else so i got
through that i was so happy i was like i
can't believe i'm seeing credits on the
game
did your switch look over to you with
the side eye
this switch is you know he's in the
cabinet right now
i usually anything that's live alive
right now right now is is exclusive to
the switch right and i was almost
tempted but that was like i'm not going
to play that right now so i'll wait till
it comes to the steam deck and it will
come
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the access gamer
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues demands nothing less than that
premium experience and is the leader of
the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how are we doing sir
well rested on this wonderful day
i looked up i said uh midweek i said
what fights we have this weekend ah they
said ufc i said we have nothing oh
damn oh damn
yeah cause you know what i could fraud
it i could fraud it and be like yeah you
watch the ufc it's not really your pick
i know right there and i'm trying to
tell dudes who look like what in the
ring yeah yeah yeah i'm like yeah but he
got him in the bare naked choker
if you have ufc streams they need to be
comedy streams
he did the toe tuck kick
so you know right now he's in copper
wetter moves
next week we got uh danny garcia versus
um
what's this guy yes he'd shay army brat
he did
[Laughter]
they got them on the floor
to be fair to be fair though like real
naked choke isn't much better is it much
better that all right true infinity
infinity
like beer naked
i ain't saying buck naked
[Laughter]
well he was like what's bjj oh
canceled me
i would have been on everybody's fraud
nah nah but i saw i saw ufc going on
over there a couple of other things um
but i was playing guardians of the
galaxy
oh
um as a comic book junkie
and as one of those people that need to
get the costumes whatever first of all
yeah the game i think this is how they
wanted to do
avengers yes
i'm gonna give you the reasons why they
[ __ ] and why they shouldn't right
the way the story is being told
and how it's crafted around star-lord
it's fantastic how you control the other
uh
uh heroes that are with your teammates
how you got a rally you got a rally
thing come on guys
we getting our butts kicked out there we
go we got to get it together you know
quail says whatever and he rallies the
troops and depending on how you rally
him it's how much super you have going
into that fight then the music is gonna
kick off after you do the journey that
the the musical aspect of it you know in
this old 80 hits yeah yeah like pat
benatar and stuff it's it's really dope
um
i love the visuals it was it was a part
where
you the universal church of truth and
you were growing up with the golden
opulence
yes i was looking at my tv like on god
this is
like i said and this is this is a last
generation game right you know but you
know we played it on current generation
hardware and dude's got to really stop
that saying next generation hardware
stuff um we're we're in current
generation sir right right so we got to
really just start transitioning over
their lives
but um looking at it visually i was like
this is
it's splendifer this this is fantastic
and the story the way the story is
driven now
as far as being a marvel head
i saw dog hawk i saw quasar i saw a red
jack i saw when i saw the blood brothers
because i was up to the blood brothers
fight and you have to separate them uh
yo
and cosmo the dog and then you get to
the collector
when you go to uh nowhere when you when
you're in that celestial brain the head
the head of the celestial there pause is
way different than the mcu it gives you
a different take it's like there's they
they stuck in the mcu
without being stuck in the mcu like
they're telling the story but they're
telling it
way better like comic book version their
writers are incredible amazing the
reason why i think that the avengers
game couldn't be like this
i was playing outriders yesterday shout
out to my son david my oldest son dave
salute i saw him on and he was with his
friends and they were playing outright
my son is playing hours
i jumped in the party
they needed help
son
can i save you for a minute
so he was like yeah yeah yeah so he said
yeah yeah yeah so we're in there playing
so his friend didn't know
uh that i said son i guess you know he
thought it was like in some new york you
know what i signed you know what i'm
saying
so
i told him we were playing and he was
like he said something i was like yeah
i'll come and take you to the movies or
whatever son
and the dude was like what i was like
yeah yeah you know dave was my son he
was like what yeah david's like yeah
that's pop dudes yeah i was like yo cool
like this and they play videos
[Music]
i don't know if the camera's working but
now the camera is good you go you're
good okay the the mic fell on my
keyboard and mouse
oh
oh look at look at this stuff no
[Music]
no it's worse it fell and it hit my
drink on my keyboard oh no
yeah you had that luckily you had a
balance he bought
the arm fell off then we got to get
through you gotta hit the back up for
that keyboard right quick yeah
i i'm pretty sure i can fix it yeah
he'll fix it but his keys would be
absolutely instead
i know how to type so i know where they
are
when you start texting people you will
figure out what you're talking about
for the people yeah it's it's it's
pretty amazing oh you're joining oh
village
you're joining us
yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's just let's just get you let's
just get it okay yeah i am bank we'll
take care of that
it's okay um
my son's friend is like oh so what's
your plan what you playing what you're
playing because he was like yeah because
my father got a podcast and almost i'm
like oh i feel really cool right
i said i'm playing guardians of the
galaxy
he's like yeah you know i would have
played that but
i'm i like being other characters and
it's just the fact that you're star-lord
and i think why they didn't do it with
the avengers because i thought about it
and i was like man if i had to play
captain america at all times yeah if
they force you with one you don't get a
chance to play
um the hulk
but
i guess they could have did it just like
i mean because they did the story like
kamala khan yes
yeah the story is the best part of that
game um
and then give that aspect to it but
i think they should have did it like uh
guardians of the galaxy but other than
that
um
i've been playing out riders yes how's
that world's late i gotta get to it man
i got to my techno man sir oh my god
turrets all day
yeah we got monkey up to level four back
he outside oh yeah monkey was outside he
was playing with uh green mason and them
yeah shout out to mason man he'd be
hitting me up it'd be always the wrong
time
yeah i saw you on uh playing on the
rocker blade
um y'all was getting it it was you jamie
yeah and um
before tay was in your chat what they
came through yeah he's playing dustin
you know
and i did some of my destiny stuff this
week but it's been really
going back to game pass because there's
a backlog and there's a game pass back
sir
right so game pass backlog be having a
time limit over your head so you look at
what was hot and you're like damn i got
to go back in there and play that before
they got rid of it and i said that with
the yakuzas
and then they was like okay yakuzas is
out this week oh snap no i didn't get a
chance to play none of them but then you
know phil down with this maximum is
really expensive bro
so i'm gonna get right back into that
but yeah that's that's what i've been
playing no doubt and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that realness in
out of iop not telling what you want to
hear what you need to hear yo say
something love to my bro um mr maddie
plays man really
hurt his back um yeah yeah
yeah so he was out this week so i had to
hold it down but yeah send some love to
him man he's doing the right thing
making sure everything is good with the
with the bulging disc and all the stuff
he's got going wow yeah he's i'm like
bro you two young back is dude
but he's on it he's on it he's doing the
right thing and um shout out to to ben
smith from last stand media holding
dance out the random thought for pulling
up pulling uh hold it down we had it
still had a solid show
shout out to ibontis and send your love
to you bontes cause i was watching you
showing your man with the ladder game oh
you listen yeah yeah yeah you said i
love you yeah he loves me he's lucky too
we're gonna get to eat a minute paul
yeah yeah yeah and give it show some
love the the home media cologne he just
lost his dad yes um yeah so please yeah
send some love man so much people going
through so many things right now man so
yeah
just got diagnosed whatever it's a lot
going on but yeah we we held it down
shot the ran for pulling up we talked
about the um
activision blizzard deal the potential
if it could in early what what that
could mean and then yo ben is outside
with this power wash simulator bro he's
like this is my gaming yeah so i'm
clowning he's like playing car what did
you play
listen
it is
weird because i was like i'm rolling my
eyes like what am i doing what is going
on here it's a soothing nature to it i
don't know how else to describe it it's
like and then it's like this what's that
thing when you do something and it gives
you the the visual satisfaction yeah
it's like this you clean the door clean
you clean the window click like it's
just this little reward thing that
mentally makes you feel good for
cleaning something
yeah it's a satisfaction that you get
from just like it is yeah it's it's it's
just weird and you got the co-option
with b-value guys that we do with our
iron power wash podcasts and i would i
can't front though when you clean
something
it's like it goes from the dirtiest
grimiest thing
to like the truck like this van that was
clean it had like raytracing it was
sparkling it was it looks super shiny
like you could see the reflection i'm
like there's got to be race tracing all
this stuff because it looked too clean
you feel too good like yo i did
you got to change that out with the red
you know what i'm saying with the power
street i'm like we really doing this fan
like you really
he getting into it you know and then
your king you gonna laugh because you
can you could crouch you could get prone
to get underneath get underneath the
tire you can get into it so i'm like all
right this game is out of pocket but i
salute to them
so shout out to uh my boys or ebantis of
course i got travis last but shout out
to you he's doing all right ridiculous
say you know falling off ladders and
doing craziness but yeah right now he's
lucky that his leg is there man i've
told him yeah because he he did what
eight feet he said he felt like well
actually he slid down to the garage when
he got to the garage it was from the
from the garage to the floor and it was
a slow fall for eve that's the worst but
you slowly
ah
he said i hit the inside of my knee bruh
how you hit the inside of here he while
it you know says so much salute he's
okay thankfully we had he resolute you
know what i'm saying shout out to him
really good artist in the community
talking about that lightfall expansion
that's about to come out they about you
about downs to date so they got
something cooking on that and then for
me on the games tip yeah finish as does
false
salute interior nights off you got to
get into that
for me for me i know i already know yeah
they they did that they did that like
again it's not gonna be for everyone i
will say that off the bat but if you
give it a chance
you can't tell me there's a better
narrative you can't tell me there's the
voice acting the tense the the stakes
the choices how it really affects and
i've talked to addict i've talked to
rand i've talked to multiple people and
there's so many differences from my game
can't play to someone else's and then
the future fate of all certain
characters and then the way it's woven
they got they got one
like i said continue to um iterate they
ended on a way that is still opening for
something else so i expect a book three
most likely but um yeah man you feel the
way you feel about these characters and
this game challenges you to make some
tough decisions multiplayer is the way
to go shout out to addict i i like what
he was doing with the gf you know david
she was getting it all out and that
override mechanic like give it a shot
man all i say is give it a shot now
again
what i think for me is the first 15-20
minutes you just gotta if you're going
to get comfortable with the r-style
because let's be honest it's kind of
still pictures with slight animation not
really emoting whatever but the beauty
of it is because of all of that i think
you could truly have all these paths and
all these choices because they chose
that style and to me the style is it's
kind of fire but that's to be salute to
them go check that out shout out to
carolyn to charu to uh the whole team at
interior night uh when we got to talk to
them [ __ ] and i knew it like we played
it we're like we knew it we were like
where did they go
they got one they really haven't yeah at
least at least the um
the
what is it the the trees and stuff
moving that game
video um how the puddle's attic how the
pose
there we go uh i had addicts a video of
it because attic has a review video up
yes he does uh he had that that was one
of those games that he was under nda for
so he didn't have the the opportunity to
do um
co-op online he had to do local no i did
i did i did uh co-op online i'm talking
about when you first had it uh before
that co-op has been uh active the whole
time it was he was able to use it it was
just the app that didn't work once yeah
out there okay
so um
but what i've noticed and what what he
expressed
is over a period of time your mind
starts to fill in the gaps from
the
the graphics
your mind starts to anticipate the
movement and you see movement that's not
there and this ghost movement changes
how it goes because i was talking to
everborn yesterday and he did the same
exact thing
he was like your game is like probably
his game of the year
it's kind of like um when you look at
something like a comment like you know
you're reading the panels
bit by bit but you're you
after you read a certain amount of you
start visualizing it in your head like
you're actually watching like an actual
movie right and the fact that they're
based on real actors it's not just you
know it's like this the stills of real
actors and real and to me they convey
emotion very well even in that thing
they have little things animated but to
me the key first i know the thing that
nobody's talking about this game has
phenomenal music
like for not like really emotional
attention music and some really good
retrospective music but the voice acting
and the actors they got are this is
movie level like this is literally we
hired because i think they got the girl
from eternals in this the dude vince is
the guy that's played in deus ex um
they've got like world-class talent like
you could tell like these performances
that they doing the narrative is so
strong it's over taking you forgetting
about the still thing because i'm like
yo this is really good but yeah salute
to my i did it the ending was was
interesting there's a lot to talk about
i probably want to do a spoiler cast
someone is it's really cool but um doing
that of course that that naraka blade
point you know i'm outside with that you
know what i'm saying get my shaolin
liquid swords on doing it up man so fire
it's just so much i talked about the
game so much you already know what it is
and then um forza i did the uh the hot
wheels expansion king i ain't gonna
front man playground with that
with that joy start up
and you see what the series x is doing
and i'm like whoa when you doing the the
loop the loops and the joint and the
grip like the 60 frames and
and then you know what it is to solve
like the field of view
so like you're driving you're seeing the
other parts of the track deep in the
distance doing the like i'm like
playground i see what it is y'all
outside you know
that's one of them joints i think i'm
gonna have to double dip on it
well i never i never get i never got i
never purchased on xbox because of the
game passenger stuff but um yeah i think
i think papa gabe might have to get that
money for that yeah i'm gonna need that
um i i've noticed this weird thing
that's going around like christopher
hart what's up um just talked about and
i haven't mentioned christopher hart in
a while yeah
he's been relatively irrelevant like
what um what's up
he's he's been making a little bit of
noise like you know like the ssd uh
what's going on with trying to put peppa
pig on xbox like peppa pig is our joint
like we rock peppa pig like peppa pig
ain't on playstation like
what's up and y'all rated it higher so
y'all enjoyed it more like y'all y'all
like
pig over there we don't really we don't
rock with the pig over the swine ain't
fine over here we don't do that over
y'all rated it very high over there so i
suggest that you wrap your peppa pig
wait it's over there i didn't even know
i it's all playstation
they're trying to act like we we are the
pavilions
in xbox games
we don't normally dip our toes in the
console or stuff besides king 2 too much
but it's just like i don't i don't
understand the capping and the putting
other games down for a game you play as
a cat
like
i i just i just like i'm not saying that
the game isn't good or bad all i'm
saying is let's be real here if there
was a game on xbox that you was playing
as a cat and it was exclusive to that
platform king do you think people would
be hyping it up like that i don't know
you know they would have been roasting
us
phil walked past that game when the
storm was like oh hell no not today
hashtag not the the one who did that
hashtag
now i heard it's really good though you
know i heard it's really good i had it
pre-ordered on the steam deck because i
was like again i'm not going to get to
play this on my place
oh no
i mean i guess it's still
if you're not going to make this part
i'm not a fan
i'm not even telling people to go out
and not play a game as a cat i'm saying
that what i see on twitter is astounding
to me oh guys you know what it is you
can't play something like like you know
even kidsmove was like liking like lucky
towels or some one of those idiotic
games that uh i wasn't a big fan
and the amount the amount of attacking
that smooth got for that game was uh
what was was inside you know was weird
energy to be is when people attack your
enjoyment of something yeah like that's
just that you're smiling weird like i
can't believe that they pray
like yo that is what if you got time to
be mad and upset and someone else you're
not having fun where you at exactly
because if you have anyone where you at
you ain't got time to be worried about
what somebody else looks like
i got a question for you yeah how many
of those play people that you've seen on
twitter the past couple years say game
pass is hurting the uh the ecosystem and
say support the developer went out there
and bought a cat a game where you play
as a cat well no no
they they playstation plus exploring
it's on plus here
it's on the premium is it also so the
devs they supported it okay
it's when it's on your side i know we
know the game bro y'all just gang
culture throwing it up for the set i
don't know what it is what it is i
wanted to have it so they had the cap
listen so that that would ever come out
week to week it's a direct comparison
i pre-ordered it on the steam deck and
last minute i was like you know what
nice i have it on the plate i would
figure out a time to play it whatever
turns out the the pc version is shot
that oh
yeah whoa
you know it's
it's a little box so they they do it
well they don't know
you best
you contributed to the problem
throwing it up for the second
you know how it is
i don't consider pointing out
contributor to the culture like
it's just like it it's crazy that you
really love it people are making fun of
me for playing as dust falls because of
what it looks like
yo and what's so stupid about it is
the cat don't poop the cat don't got no
little bites
this is what i'm just saying i mean if
you're gonna really be a cat be a cat
though yeah yeah this is just messy you
just who playing what i'm playing i'm
having more fun than you
that's what this is i've had it before
okay so listen this is how the tweet
started right okay what happened
somebody put up this thing is thirty
dollars and it took me three hours to
beat
so i just put ten dollars an hour at the
double why it's ten dollars an hour
i don't there's nothing wrong with ten
dollars an hour and then it went bananas
like god
you're monetizing how much
a game should be for fun like you're not
saying anything about the games it was
like 20 hours king and you i just said
ten dollars an hour it that that's all
it was and i didn't say the game was bad
because i didn't play it i didn't say it
was too much it was just an accurate
assessment of the breakdown of three
hours and it's ten dollars and it's a
good game for 30 bucks for 30 bucks
i would do 30 bucks on it
but 10 dollars an hour that's what it is
so every hour with 10 bucks and play a
different level it's your opinion again
i don't get it you're going to say it
dudes these are really funny with the
weird energy when you play something but
anyway so yeah that that's been that
and get into the pool man with the
acquisition of bungie now finalized by
saudi which outcome do you think will
happen first during their tenure as a
playstation studio the winner of the
three-way ilp poll with a commanding 62
percent of the vote was the messy lords
i don't care we all know how bungie does
in relationships she will find a way to
be single once again as a studio okay
coming in that second at 29 of the vote
was bungie completes and releases one of
the 10 rumored live service games for
sony first group and in last space and
only seven percent of the vote was that
destiny 3 will release first before the
live service game so salute everybody
who rocked the pole all that good stuff
addict man they saying that they feel
it's inevitable that bungie will
eventually be leave if there's a
relationship to work
it just depends if if matter does well
uh because then
they're going to have to support matter
and destiny what am i close and
what can you move
it's literally right here
because when you go like this is go low
i'm just telling you i mean it's
literally right at my house
you don't like to get real with it
you gotta cut
here's the thing like this is literally
as far as this goes like i can't make it
any further
necking
you would say about the budgie
it's just i i gotta see how they're able
to support multiple products and if
they're able
here's the thing even if bungie wants to
leave i don't know
if once they see that real money popping
through there because i activision was
supporting them but activision wanted
money bungie wants uh
sony wants growth
like that that's different i feel like
they're gonna hit they're gonna do
different things with bungie and once
bungie starts getting that that you know
the media thing going on where they're
making movies tv shows it's not going to
be a matter if they want to leave them
but who says in five years if destinies
make it if destiny or matter is making
the kind of money that maybe even
entertainment doesn't make them maybe
they start making more money in other
avenues to where it's like even if we
want to leave we can't leave because we
have we're so intertwined at this point
with media it's a different types of you
know let's say they start working and
put more uh
not disney but destiny stuff on uh
different
uh different
you know models like uh you know amazon
netflix
i don't know at that point
if they'll be able to leave without
sacrificing that arm of their company
interesting interesting i feel yeah i
feel you that's all i got on that we're
going to get into these topics man um
attic you're up yes yes you wanna let me
get these super chats before we chat
yeah let's get in
get
again
sony and sony fanboys be finding ways to
take an l every week
the last of us part one was a cash crap
even with part two features but without
them it's even worse
and we'll talk about that eventually
we're gonna get there
then we got white cog two dollars with a
chair
quote i saw you and dj in there getting
it on
wow wow that's what we're doing where
was this quoted from i had like no
what's funny is i did say that when he
was talking about playing
four guys
there we go ko3 black truth 10 super
chat did y'all set a tear like i did
watching the black panther trailer uh we
want to address this now
yeah let's get to it um
oh i thought kate was gonna jump in i
mean look for me i didn't hear nothing
i'm sorry yeah we talked about somebody
talking about the uh black craft today
it's a it's it's very i'm torn because
there's a part of me that i understand
obviously recipes chad what you know
what i mean but um
yeah there's a part of me there's a good
debate going on i actually empathize
with both sides if you put a gun in my
head the answer for me will be i feel
the character should not be killed off
and recast but i understand like i'm not
not you know empathetic to what they're
trying to do
um
it's a tough one for me you know what
i'm saying because it's like it's a real
life situation being implemented into
the movie lore of black panther and most
likely based on what we see in it or
soon maybe shuri
i wouldn't reserve judgment until i see
the movie before i go off or be
disrespectful or anything like that the
trailer was was good i liked the name oh
he asked what how yeah so you know for
me it's just i need to see like i just
the reason why i feel so strongly and i
give it to king because king knows the
lord better than me the reason why i
feel so strongly is because the original
black panther was a movement like there
was a pride that we finally get the
character that we know you know what i'm
saying for black culture and now that he
in real life is going i don't know if
chadwick would have wanted that to the
the the character to go he definitely
did not want right so that's where i
feel i'm torn because it's like i want
black panther like put it this way i
think they work their way out of that
right and maybe it's a progression
that's why i'm going to chill and
reserve just yeah maybe it's they're
going to progress to it because like my
thing is if and i'm not i'm not trying
to make this racial anything if any
other character
gets killed kill it off right if chris
dies there's going to be died then they
ain't us right right we're gonna stop
capping like uh chadwick is the black
panther chadwick it's chadwick boseman
when chad mc played uh the baseball
player um
he's dead uh uh or he's
he's alive whatever the hell it is is
this the fact that when he played jackie
robinson
um
you don't kill off jackie robinson yeah
he's passed
stop associating with and we're gonna
stop doing it with these characters of
color well first of all we ain't gonna
do it um
but i i do i do say this and uh and you
know yeah i might get a little bit
fluffy i don't know i don't really care
um
the fact that
in the books the black panther goes on
to become the king of the dead yeah that
actually happens yeah curry actually
becomes the black panther that is true
right so that mantle of leadership is
passed on and transferred over so maybe
the movie changed from exactly what it
would have been because you would have
got a little bit more of chadwick
bozeman as black panther okay yeah we
could be upset with that part we can
understand that but he has that
character has to be recast right yes
what happens is um we saw the birth
and it could be a birth of a son right
that that that birth of a son could be
the growth of the new black panther when
sherry takes on you know neymar and uh
the atlanteans and she finds out that
fine fighting she's not you know that's
not what that's not what she is about no
exactly she's tony stark that's who she
is like
yes
right so she's not the warrior so you
have the dominante
that are there for the warrior aspects
of chadwick boseman uh encompassed the
greatest mind of tony stark and the
greatest warrior that we've seen right
so
i guess it will be trying to follow that
but we haven't really found out exactly
what happened to killmonger right right
because we understand that uh his cousin
didn't want him to go so they could have
put him in chronogetic free yep like
they did the winter soldier when they
were trying to heal his mind and have a
redemption story with him exactly
could definitely say my cousin's gone
and i'm gonna i'm gonna take this part
i gotta get past this anger that i have
right right and and and and evolve and
and be there for my people exactly that
would be a beautiful story to me because
he he was a good king
right it's just that his focus was in
the wrong area place
it came from anger and hate exactly from
uh he wanted get back sober revenge so
bad but yeah trilla looks dope uh recast
that character because that character
should not be locked away uh because uh
his real-life actor that played him
right he took a role
and played him over the years we have
different supermen we have different
batmen we have a whole bunch of
different characters that we did not
lose the joker once uh uh heath legend
passed away right so good point don't
don't do that yeah i do feel like it is
i think the multiverse the multiverse
gives them the out right i think yeah
yeah multiverse could be let attic get
his balls off yeah
i do feel like
black panther and joker can't really be
compared because the joker's one entity
and black panther is a title that they
give to people in wakanda so
like if you kill off joker you can never
use the joker again like
all you have to do is pass the power to
someone else you use black panther again
yeah but i think the thing is i think we
say it that way we're saying it that way
but we mean t'challa don't care don't
fall off t'challa but i i i thought we
were talking about black panther like
the i think we mean the character we
mean the character of t'challa
yeah
not the the the the mantle believe
uh leadership not not that aspect of it
we're talking about the actual character
of t'challa himself just because
chadwick passed away that the character
trichala didn't pass away he's a
fictional character in a book
that is written in his cast so let's say
chadwick never got that role
right and somebody else got that role
that is highly possible these things
happen so and and this precedent and
we'll move on cause we're going along
but yeah this president is spartacus
remember that right
season it was too much money involved
and now even though what you call didn't
die but remember terence howard was war
machine yeah it was initially before
yeah
a different story they probably would
have recasted i think that like
the thoughts that marvel is like if we
recast it's disrespecting chad as a
person
and i think that's what the mindset is i
think that's exactly what their mindset
is all i'm going to say is
before i flip and go crazy i'm going to
give them the benefit that i have not
seen this movie i need to see it and i
and maybe the out is what you said king
and solved which is down the road we
have the multiverse aspect you know and
it's a smoother transition and then it
happens that way so
judgment until you see
i think the sister's just going to play
black panther
i don't i don't
they might pass the torch again later on
down the future but it probably won't be
to like face seven or something i think
she's going to beat him for a while kill
her i think they kill her before this
movie is over because of all the trouble
that was going on on set so that's a
whole different thing we could do with
that [ __ ] other thing yeah that's a
whole other thing too yeah yeah i think
her character is killed off regardless
to what that's why i when i saw the
birth of the child i said that might be
the lead in to the next club right they
could be doing that right
there's a whole bunch of things that you
can do with that but
i don't ever want to over look the
killmonger aspect of it because what
marvel doesn't do is they don't vault
away characters that they don't use
later and be it what if because they
brought them back and what if
oh i said you said that yeah the fact
that you're able to use said character
in this aspect that means that that
character is still available in your
docket they're going to use it we'll see
anyway good question and um they say
attic i'm like a little hot now even
though i'm close i'm sorry i do i made
you go close but now they just turned
the ball i haven't moved no you're good
just the volume just the ball just
slightly i haven't i haven't messed with
the mic the the volume either
how about i
i mean i can put it a little farther
away
that might be i'm sorry bro i know i'm
asking you a bunch of stuff i keep
forgetting the keyboard that mostly um
soft super chat
party cindy five dollars if you chat
salute to the lords on the sizzling
sunday i hope you can keep nice and cool
thank god for air conditioning yeah
parkee thank you thank god
yes sir
simon mckenzie 10 super chat just
showing love keep up the great work
brothers thank you sir appreciate that
man
and we got lognet's finest flame
remember for 22 months
good afternoon my brothers it seems my
trip to daviri in warframe last week
left me with some homesickness feeling
better but warframe is outside yeah
you're doing a warframe shout out to the
lord's game with everybody outside with
that warframe go check out the articles
about it i remember when i saw that at
the xbox one launch i was like what the
hell is this
and look and look at it and look at it
that's crazy it held on it build it it's
like mold
it builds itself up in the corner and
now it's out of control that's a lot of
controversy
so we got raiden blade remember for 17
months hey bros i'm listening paying
full attention but living up in the
world or leveling up in world slayer the
last of us part one put that in the
bushes i don't care it should be 40 to
50 pounds no more you gonna get into it
and get into it that's for sure and we
got donald taco two dollar super chat my
friend peppa pig is lit though
[Laughter]
variety game pass varieties
then we got mandingo mcthicken uh he's
back he back five dollar super chat
so to be clear
the last of us two cost a couple hundred
million to make the last of us one
re-remake re-re-remake
costs a couple hundred bucks to make
yeah both are seventy dollars word
we gotta get it
and it's less of a game you can't forget
that
save your bars
apologies i got plenty of bars i know
you do
you ready you already got the gun
ready ambient noise uh the bronx is
while they're not today his party's
going i don't know i actually don't know
the windows behind me so i'm assuming
everything behind me it catches me no i
don't hear i don't hear anything
beautiful perfect perfect now how the
mic goes is when you're in front of it
it because my uh
air conditioner conditioners like right
here and you guys can't hear it yeah
tough right now okay beautiful perfect
perfect
let me stop snitching on myself
then we got hollywood rules member for
seven months thank you sir another
fantastic iop sunday with my four
cousins from around the way talking
games hello
what a night for the mcu that wakanda
trailer though yeah
people was in their fields one way or
another they went in the fields over
this trailer that's for sure no question
now we got harkie cheney once again five
dollar super chat the last of us two
still hasn't delivered any multiplayer
content may come next year after three
years and you have to pay extra hashtag
delay the last of us two hashtags sony
charges too much we gonna get to it
they're ready they got they they what
this type of thing what adding stomach
that we got the homie general back
remember for 22 months gee
oh hell the iop salute the lord shout
out to the chat if you play meta quest 2
i challenge you to play contractors best
vr show yeah yeah yeah yeah we got that
we got that together yes it shouted
that's his joy is it like a hitman type
he's a murderer
[Music]
you know like murder contractors like
assassins no no not god
this running game that that the
longest-running first-person game you
talk about like counter-strike
yeah yeah
yeah oh okay
that sounds good what else we got all
right hollywood rules five dollars super
chat i totally agree with cog love chad
t'challa he should be recast i think
feige is playing with words we will get
it to tala from another universe
that's what i feel like is the better
the better the solution
is the dude who played uh killmonger i
feel like him from a different universe
is
like he's he's someone he's a he's still
wrong in a different universe and he
gets stuck in this universe somehow i'd
rather take him from this universe and
be unfrozen and being reprogrammed like
they did the winter soldier i mean they
were able to meld his mind
mcu they could bring them back somehow
because yeah but he was nobody
for him right
no he said i mean he told he remember at
the end he tells him like i don't want
to be a prisoner i don't want he don't
want that
yeah but he said you know sometimes
people don't do what you want
that's true
we're gonna put we gonna put codes and
kill bandra
i would not be surprised
not laters
[Laughter]
how are you going to justify what you're
soldiering someone else
with the soldier killmonger we gotta do
with that
because
it because they will come that they
could do it in a way that's not good
to do some suspects
what they're gonna do is they could do
it in a
yeah anyway
let's say they're getting a butt kick by
neymar
and they only got to kill margaret but
in their presence
it would be horrible king they they
pressed that button kelmarker shows up
and then they all getting owned by it
you
to actually be effective they have to re
put him back into the black shirt
because as soon as he's done with name
or they hit the killmonger kill button
[Music]
reversing that that uh that programming
just like winter soldier is yup but not
and then he gonna be the next he'll be
the next big bad guy he's gonna be here
you're gonna be able to control that boy
they have a real kill manga switch and
just yeah
it's
[Laughter]
mcu needs blue marble black man with op
powers and intelligent and has a great
story okay they got to do it before um
warner brother does it
let's go all right then we have dude
hold on a second we got gaming forte
five dollars super chat happy sunday
lords hope all as well and as always
hey king boo-boo
i got that i got that they save it man
right now they gotta drink the meals
okay
then we have server error with the two
pound super chat
if peppa is worth forty dollars and the
last of us remake is at least two times
that
all right
so we got hollywood rules five dollars
per champ that birth was neymar being
born child had wings on his feet i think
they're pandering as a black man
recasting t'challa too important not to
exist that is true
hold on a second then we got the homie
fonzarelli
brother
i'm with you all as well don't cut off
the challah his character is too big to
just let go definitely don't want his
sister taking the man
i wonder if the reason they're not doing
it is because they knew his situation
and it was always in the story that he
would get killed off it's just they
didn't know when
well he was supposed to become king of
the dead anyway
it's that that aspect of it does happen
in the books and is probably one of the
best reads when shuri does become the
black panther she is a little bit more
vicious than he is a little bit more
cutthroat she she rules a little bit
differently than he does but black
panther has to go on and guard the the
land of the dead
and and he's not there to you know to
govern at that period of time it's just
a different story line in the books and
and i think kruger was going to explore
that regardless yeah should be
interesting i can't wait to see before i
catch judgment once we got something
okay and then we got suicide kings two
dollars super chat the last of us topic
make king walk through the metal
detector
hey you ready for
for 25 months thank you brother thank
you chiming in and we have more time let
me scroll slowly slowly slowly let me
run back a little bit just to make sure
i think we're
good got one point
cloud gave me five dollar super chat
so far facebook the mcu was
underwhelming to be honest i got
emotional nonetheless such an awesome
trailer and tribute to chadwick bozeman
no doubt he said phase four was
underwhelming a lot of people saying
that king obviously
it was it was underwhelming i feel it
doesn't have direction and here's the
thing like
like but here like i it was
underwhelming to me but i i don't think
phase four was ever supposed to be
wowing like we just went off of the
thanos thing like this is pre-building
back up to another epic battlefield yeah
but
faith
okay so i i i tend to do this i think
like phase four was uh shoring up the
power of the streaming aspect of disney
plus
because all the shows that we did get
for the disney plus aspect of it push
the narrative forward little by little
to give you uh quality shows at home
as well as the big budget stuff in the
movies i thought thor loving thunder was
fantastic um i'm thinking these shows is
really good like miss marvel and stuff
like that yeah they're giving you
different characters i think a lot of
people are not considering people not
considering the shows as part of the
phase but it is though but it is though
it is it really is so yeah i think it's
a different look than what we know
so far i think that's another thing that
streaming service has restructured how
they do things because it used to be
they would probably try to make you know
uh a movie but instead of making a movie
it's like let's just make it a tv show
they i i think it's like they have a
little bit more of a middle ground like
there's a character that gauges interest
but they don't know if they want to make
it to a full-blown movie then let's make
it to a tv show
see how the interactions are with the
fans and if depending going on there
we'll see if we want to use that
character
we get more daredevil
and then you saw a freshman you saw uh
spider-man yeah
it's been 97 yeah man don't don't throw
off as uh you know um
the fourth phase
as throw away i think the four phase
like attic says is bricklaying for the
foundation going forward um yeah you did
this huge jesus before you got to keep
in mind that they
they're still dealing with losing
iron man losing captain america jordan
has one foot out the door at this point
too
it's just like they know they're going
to have to rotate people and have people
take the place and doctor strange must
be worried he's been at this for a
minute at this point so it's just like
they know this isn't about just building
a universe this is about who's who's on
the way out that we have to replace in
the in the near future yeah and then the
fox deal and all that too that's why you
see yeah that's why
they're doing stuff the eternals like
they're trying to
you know build up a bunch of characters
so they can decide who does what where
yeah yeah
i feel that
anyway good
yeah i think we're caught up all right i
guess we are here for the main event
everybody here you're good you're set up
not good
uh one last super chat before we start
necromancer zell ten dollar super chat
there's too much marvel in too short a
time also we're in the lower rung
characters most people don't know or
care about i don't trust disney anymore
with classic characters
be crazy
i've been hearing that a lot of people
are you crazy i don't care
here's the thing though like like on god
in them no no no no first of all you
dudes are weirdos
we don't care about first of all kamala
khan basically differ um all these
characters that are actually coming at
you you saw monica rambo you don't even
know who photon is and you're sitting
there you capping like these things you
saw white vision i think white vision
actually happened this is this stuff is
actually happening i think what it is
i don't want to read i think i think
what it is is we're coming off of
the best couple movies that the phase
one through three had to offer and now
people are going into this next phase
which is literally rebuilding it up we
don't even know who the main attacker
is all cap
okay let me finish my might here
go ahead
and i think what it is is people have
this high expectation because of end
game because of infinity war now every
movie they're like if it doesn't hit me
like those movies hit me we got issues
and it's just like look like that is the
conclusion you're never going to get the
same type of thing from that type of
engagement like that
infinity war some are probably of the
best movies that's ever been around
it was insane now
i'ma say this it was two it was you guys
that saw those last two movies you
didn't support none of the other movies
some of you did some of you did you came
in for infinity war and in friendly
gauntlet and you like that's the
greatest movies ever and everything else
after that is trash you don't know the
story you don't know nothing
and it can't be nothing else greater
than this y'all guys came in on the high
you jumped in on the boat when it was
all the way at the peak and the roller
coaster goes down and it goes back up
those are the fraud dudes
and these are dudes yeah i'ma tell you
right now uh it was the greatest so did
you see iron man 3 well not really well
you know what i
um
did you see guardians of the galaxy too
you remember when ego
well uh what happened
which is the reason these dudes is only
there for two movies
here's the thing too is they i think
they hyper focused on a couple
characters during the first couple
phases they're trying to do
the way it's looking like and i don't
know anything about comic books but the
way i was told is now they're going to
be focusing more on like what's going on
earth what's not going on on earth
there's going to be more directions and
main stories than just like one key
component like i think in phase six
there's two avengers in one year
so clearly they're not focusing on one
independent story and in order to do
that effectively you have to tell
multiple stories throughout the years to
get to that point oh they're coming for
cake there's like king is gonna get
wrong i'm sorry kid is captain first of
all let me let the last one
[Laughter]
someone needs to pop in with that with
that with that lightning bolt and throw
it straight through his chest
what's up with all the chatter down
there
say when that money said you want to be
heard i'm not real so these are the dude
that's not supporting these are the
deaths
you support and y'all can play in the
bushes don't think i'm gonna listen to
you i actually don't like it as much as
i don't think phase four like lived up
to my expectations i would have liked it
to be i didn't mind it like i i wasn't a
big fan of dr strange's uh multiverse
madness whatever the hell that movie was
called
uh and you know the the the last movie i
even forgot what it was called already
i thought that was okay it was it wasn't
exceptional by any means but i i really
like them
i liked a lot of the the tv shows oh
come on time out time
he said i read the comics king the 2010
comics plus comics are garbage i
remember the 80s 90s and early 2000s
comics were far better so he he's like
yeah it's not me now again
how do you feel about necromancer you
just do that lightning bolt straight
through his chest no he threw a
lightning bolt and you saw me sitting
there rubbing up the berries and the
juices on my chest and i told my son to
beat him up and wow
listen listen and if y'all didn't see
thought you were in trouble because like
we just spoiled it
well they wouldn't have known unless you
didn't say anything
we'll know now you mr spoiler alert
um
did y'all like thought the dark world
all your guys that i want a serious
story i want a serious boring thing
about the second one that's the second
one
dark world was utter trash and a first
thor movie was type slight garbage as
well so when they when tyka got over and
he did his his joint thor ragnarok that
saved that franchise that allowed it to
breathe and this last movie definitely
gave it some some legs two weekends in a
row it's been number one i can't get out
of these fake fans talking all this
stuff and then i read the books you
don't read the book king might be
books but he didn't read the books king
might be on to something uh too like i
do feel like the avengers that they are
building up to take over the the
avengers that are out the door
i don't feel like none of them are as
like characters
charismatic is like any of the other
ones
i will say doctor strange like he's one
of the last remaining ones um i will say
uh
that's all that's like really memorable
like i i i can't really like i'm not
saying that they don't have that the
umph
but what what i will say is
like i just don't
know
i mean yeah i mean once you get blaire
you get mahershala in there like
but they're not here though they're not
here right right
on the mcu podcast
i have not tried to be here for six
hours today
you know why this happened well this
happened because we were supposed to do
that loving thunder
exactly
see attic no because me and attic were
sitting there like yo let's let's get it
popping and yo let me tell you right now
every time i turn on my tv cog is on the
uh on the podcast
so i said there's no way that this guy
could do anything whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa is blight supposed to be pg-13
there's no way you can make a blade
pg-13 it's like trying to make it's just
trying to make um
oh what's his name deadpool deadpool
pg-13 maybe the fight is bad but come on
man
pg-13
so well let's see let's see what it
happens
along um
clearly the chat likes the mcu talk we
might talk about making some form of
content when it comes to yeah that
happens i do it every week what the hell
are you talking about
but unless we were here unless unless i
go
hold on unless i edit that
unless i edit that for the most part you
don't see that unless you're on the
website so
logic gaming down in that lord's minute
make sure you check that out king the
prince ty
fantastic we were doing this every week
i was like forget them topics yeah they
want to talk mcu like they i've never
seen this like the chat does not want to
talk gaming they want to talk you know
why this this weekend is san diego
comics
yeah and let me tell you something if
everything was in order me and cog would
have been out there we would probably
transition straight to pax right after
that and yeah yeah yeah we obviously see
you guys like this content
that's clearly i mean well look it's
very culture game culture during culture
it's a cross section no doubt well it's
like it's like i told you guys i will
work with them and we'll we'll do
something for your mcu tastes yes yes oh
ko three black truth or solve i think
that's what we're at
yeah we got a couple hold on a second
i'm copy pasting one yeah because i got
i'm caught up so i'm going to get to
life
so where's the iop marketing department
he's helping with the question
so hold on hold on so we got necromancer
10 super chat so did did you read the
book yeah
okay so we got ko3 black truth five
dollar super chat my bad didn't mean to
start no beef just thought the trailer
was the beautiful chicken
you're good you're good it just sparked
a great discussion there's no beef it
was just a great discussion
yeah edwin garcia five dollars for chat
i think neil has a big ego and ever
since he took over naughty dog you have
time in the background carl yeah both of
them running at the same time
the games have become too dark they need
new leadership in my opinion
yeah
you just became more real
yeah well we got lord metroid five
dollars if we chat the main issue with
the current marvel is disney they let
writers and producers
they let their right they are not comic
book writers and artists to begin with i
don't agree
it's different it's a different medium
you can't just just keep just keep
reading we can't do this
10 minutes every time i think they
respect the source material um but i
won't discount their their
interpretations of the characters yeah
okay just keep going necromancers
they'll five dollars which had x-men and
fantastic four are going to make or
break them i would agree yeah i would
agree there those are important they're
going to be in trouble with this they
messed those especially x-men yeah yeah
we'll bring put up on that man yeah
please let's do that alvin five dollars
which had king's been absolute facts
folks want to jump straight from
infinity war to secret wars without the
build-up
all right that's fair that's fair then
we got ty casares 15 super chat what
black heroes need a game for me blade
and storm would be awesome also if you
want my face king i'll give it to you i
give it to you for those brows
for 26 months shout out to you brother
i'll tell you what they mess up the
x-men and we're gonna have problems
they call them x people and i'm yelling
in all caps all over twitter
they're echoing
oh yeah listen man we gotta see how i go
down how the mutants identify as how
they identify what's wrong yeah
well they think they did
man
big thickets five dollars in a chat thor
loving thunder was not good
iron man one is still at the top five
along with winter soldier infinity wars
civil war and end game king is off his
medication
all right he got a kick
oh no
loving thunder isn't good compared to
what metric and what barometer he said
iron man went to soldier
you're talking about you sat there and
cherry picked uh uh the field go through
those thor movies and you cherry picked
the best there's four of them so which
ones are the best ones that's that's
let's if you want to play that game what
don't look and say well you know i i
don't like thor compared to iron man
don't do that compare those four doors
and you tell me which ones but i can
tell you what you're doing yeah i can
tell you which ones are the best the
last two
so stop with the cap stop trying to make
it fit your narrative only person that
needs meds is you and what i want you to
do is step back
you can use this the nose spray use it
in your eyes
yeah we will never get r rated from
disney i hope that's not true gamer by
choice
deadpool oh yeah i want a goodyear
they're not changing deadpool i want a
good hulk story in the movie world
breaker they're doing that all right so
mark ruffalo has signed he signed on for
four more projects right what that
that's cool
what this amazing is the four projects
is going to be that world breaker hawk
is going to be on the disney channel uh
this was talked about in san diego comic
con so um it's going to be broken up
into four parts but then what they're
trying to say is that that just only
encompass one project so hopefully
that's it and hopefully the she-hulk is
the second project and he has two more
projects that's left in the mcu i would
love to see hulk versus hercules at some
point because i think him and thor will
have to team up in order to beat
hercules sounds like the chat one's
kicking
how you feel about that last of us yeah
i mean you know we're here at our little
podcast we're going to talk about games
because clearly the chat was a separate
branch of iowa i'm sorry i we we had to
answer the people
let's keep the mcu no slumber
maybe the three-hour walk maybe
anyway so um attic man this is what the
people here for
do you want me to set it up you want to
talk about what's going on with the last
of us man
yeah i i'll set it up let's go
uh i can't see i can't make it more
dramatic because i can't get the mic
closer to me but
look man so
there's been obviously we got a last of
us remake coming
and a lot of us thought that you know it
was going to be a relevant remake a
remake of all remakes
a remake that
that everyone just
wants to point out and said that was my
game
but we didn't get that
uh we we didn't get read
combat or any kind of gameplay mechanic
improvements besides the ps5 tax
the
haptic feedback
and the
what's that other whack thing they do
the 3d audio
so that's actually hot it's actually
really good
so we we we didn't get none of that but
you know we got king get guess what we
got king what we got sir
we we got a 70 dollar title
and you know what you know what that you
know what that gets you key
well it's there it get it gets you a
a little bit you know a little bit
better looking game you know what else
it gets you king well it gets me sir it
gets you some you know some some more
stuff that ps5 tax they're going to put
that ten dollars on there for you to
access there's again a faction did we
get the facts
i'm getting there okay
i'm hungry man
you know what it doesn't get you what it
don't get me it doesn't get you half the
game
wait wait wait wait so addy okay let me
let me get this right
they're releasing the game that's a
remake on the playstation this is a
playstation 3 game right
but this is a remake of a remake from a
playstation 3 game to a playstation 4
game but every time it jumps platforms
it loses more content
actually you know what's you know what's
you have a better chance
we lose more content but the price go up
here the tag team i'm kicking
that you have a better value to go out
there and pick up that ps4 version well
no i say you can go just pick up the ps3
version just play
[Music]
because you get the whole game is it
entirely right it comes with factions
and code with all that stuff so all
right so wait a second you got a
playstation 5 with less content paid
more but don't use the features inside
the box wait a second
three
they're stuffed inside of playstation
four but they they i mean and then
playstation five but they're giving you
playstation five prices i got it i got
it now i got it so you you know what's
funny too king is the fact that
people are trying to justify this now
i'm not gonna say you shouldn't go out
there and buy this if you really love
last of us and you want to play that
game that's one thing go out there and
pay that over price 70 for half a game
that you paid for in 2013 in 2014. all
i'm saying
is that
it is okay to support it but still deem
it
not cool
and i feel like a lot of people feel
like you can only be on one side or the
other i'm confused
what are you confused about king does it
come with all the dlc because the last
of us one had a lot of deals it doesn't
come with all of it it just lasted this
one had one dlc they had one dlc i
thought i thought he had two dlc's
because i don't know i just left
the dlc is upgraded everything is
upgraded so you just get the um
the last of us in this complete story
upgraded right um and i think that's
good
i think the cut scenes and certain
things was overhauled but if you look at
like some of the gameplay
it doesn't look that much better than
the original game like
gameplay itself what i heard was updated
it was just the visual upgrades uh from
the playstation 4. they took it to the
next level
so
i don't know i'm i'm in a part where i
say
for new players that want to play a good
story that they don't know about and i'm
with paris lilly here
um
there's no new story content to it so 70
should not be the price tag of it i
think maybe 40 50 bucks i'm i'm with
that in along with that price line of it
but again
um
if for the for the new people coming in
this is a huge bargain on a great game
for those people so
it's it's about what you deem
uh yeah worthy of your seventy dollars
i i don't i don't know it's just a
comment from beyonce and i and i will
say that look i'm not gonna say a
hundred percent that this was like some
some
what like deceiving marketing
uh because they were using words like
rebuilt from the ground up you know what
i'm saying but then when you look at the
game
when you look at the game it just looks
like it's a rock above ground up like it
doesn't look that drastic now it's like
i said the cutscenes they redid a lot of
stuff like that it does look like it but
as far as like the gameplay and when
you're going around shooting people
which is 80 of the game for the most
part
it doesn't look drastically better it
just looks you know you could tell i
will say it is visually different you
could tell it's different but is it 70
dollars different
i don't know and especially if you're
looking at from the count that they're
taking away the factions that was in the
game there's no multiplayer in it you
know
it's just
to me
the ps4 version is still a better option
than this version because at least you
get the factions you get actually play
and and i just i don't understand if you
did all that work
why not just go the extra mile and give
them the factions too obviously it's
because they have this free to play i
don't know if it's going to be free
factions that's coming out next year but
to me you put out this product
and
not only did you strip some of the
features out of the product
but you're giving it at a a at a a
pretty much like it's a brand new
product
price point and that's why that's what
your main issue is yeah
it's not even 60 it's 70. so so not only
they're like you know what king we're
going to charge you 70
for the campaign that looks better
we're not going to give you the factions
that was in this game we ain't doing
that and you know what we're gonna
charge sixty dollars but you know what
king they want to play this on the ps5
so we're gonna have to put that ten
dollar playstation five tax on on the
end of this because if you want that
hectic feedback and the 3d audio you're
going to pay us for that i know we
promoted that stuff costs money man and
you know the fast ssd
here's my thing i know it costs money
but i paid five hundred dollars to
access those things that was just i
don't want to be club brother drinks or
not i don't really nickel and dime i
don't want to get nickel and dimed every
time i want to play don't come to this
club this club is all about the payers
not the players so when you're walking
500 to get in the door plus we're going
to hit you with a little bit of side
attacks boom boom
if you if the stockx line is on this
side you can expediate it inside but
once you're inside
everything costs oxygen costs
of course
yo with this the sounds that's coming
out the speakers you pay a 10 attacks to
get the audio in the club
[Music]
and god forbid that you see people
dancing because you have to see it i
just ten dollars also and if you want
the upgraded glasses because they give
you 3d glasses when you walk in if you
want to upgrade it
we know that sony's for the players
right now they for the payers
here's the thing though
sony
i have no problem with trying to go out
there and get money because that's what
that company does sure it's slimy maybe
they should be a little bit more to the
people that actually invest into their
playstation day one because i personally
feel like they've been they've been
taking advantage of them people since
day one
but at the end of the day
i do feel like the consumer should speak
up and i don't think a lot of them do
they're like oh they did enough they
turned their twitter off they literally
know but
i i get that but even if sony turns
their quote-unquote twitter off
they're gonna see it does they can't the
whole company can't turn their twitter
over how do you go
here's the thing no i i don't i don't i
don't believe in that we've seen
multi-trillion dollar companies bend the
knee to the to twitter so they've been
there
to fortnight but no but see no here's no
here's the thing like
one of these games i think it was
spider-man you had you had to pay for
the upgrade or something twitter got at
the ass and they reversed that they
reversed it
so it like sony will reverse stuff they
reverse that
they reverse it they reversed a couple
things since they but it's just like
when it comes to this ten dollars charge
you more for the pc version but but when
it comes to this ten dollar fee that
people's like
like look
i'm not saying that the industry
shouldn't be charging at seventy dollars
i do feel like
how many how many generations we're
going to go without that increase
to the cost of the game i don't agree
they gotta do it
i don't know
you don't like to upset the tone no i
don't i don't like dumb dudes do because
they looking they're curious when
they're doing it
okay you know what's crazy you was crazy
i interrupt the chat on my on me man in
the comment section i thought we keep
going back and forth every time i mind
my business i'm in my phone you'll be
like right king
did i say right king no i didn't i
thought i was doing a tag two
commercials i didn't know what was
happening
i've been patiently waiting to talk
all i'm saying when we run dmc when you
say so
that's right
you gotta bring me you gotta bring me
some coffee when you jump oh
look if somebody wants to do this that's
up to them but i feel like i feel like
people are just like okay do it like you
know
xbox did the the xbox live thing i feel
like because both
fan bases band together they're like yo
man
call phil we need to change this we
can't do this like we're getting
destroyed on twitter we're getting
ratioed everything we post so they
naturally reverse that but it's just
like something's as easy as being shot
and it would be different if i saw like
significant features but when we go back
to just the 10 upgrade for the ps5
features
again
you shouldn't have to pay a 10 ps5 tax
to access the features that they
promoted to you
promoting the ps5
that's just my opinion
you know a lot a lot a lot of strong
feedback a lot of strong
you know this is what attic is saying a
lot of i see i see a lot of that on
twitter as well so now that the dust has
settled last of us remake what are your
thoughts on this controversy
so this this is for them to create more
fluidity between the show
that's upcoming and bringing new people
to the game right because the hope is
that they watched the show and was like
well this is awesome
let's go play this video game that i
never thought about even playing right
and when they go they're gonna see well
damn hopefully their ps5 is out in a
while but they're going to be like okay
this is the version right
they want a version out there that's
modern that has all of the things that
people expect of a modern game
and i understand it from that point of
view right but i think attic pointed
something out that that's key right when
it comes to
appealing to people that have played the
game already right the hardcore that
played the game on ps3 they played the
rema the the remaster on ps4 when you
look at that i'm hearing a baby it's a
baby
i agree
i agree
there's a whole child in the background
that's right
so when you look at that i get it from
the hardcore point of view because
when you look at the game right they sat
there for 10 minutes and they told us
all the beautiful hot new stuff you
could do oh you the walls deform when
you shoot them now now the things that
you could bump into are are are a lot
more um but the things that we really
wanted to see and and what we've seen of
remakes of lane this is the thing when
you think about
when you think about you know uh
resident evil 2 right when you even
think about a game like the saturn the
colossus remake which is a kind of a
moment for moment remake a completely
different art style remade from the
ground it looks and feels different but
it is that game that's kind of what at
the minimum i hoped and expected from
this
and here when you look at it in practice
they might have done a whole bunch of
beautiful things underneath the hood but
in practice when you look at it like i
don't look that much different like
you didn't add exposition to it right if
you would have taken
last of us one is is more it is a
smaller game right they last of us too
they turned it and i called it this one
when i played it i was like it feels
like splinter cell they turned it into a
stealth simulator if they would have
taken those same properties and tried to
apply them and really got i said go the
extra mile with this with this remake
and and make that game feel more alive
then i'm like all right cool
everything i've seen is aesthetic and
that is cool in it of itself to make the
best
uh the best version of the of that game
but when you look at it in practice it
doesn't seem much different it just
doesn't feel much different so i get the
argument that it's a cash grab or
whatever and then there was again this
didn't come from sony but
the early the early leaks that we that
we heard about this game coming out
some of the statements made around it by
people in the know they got this
information was like yeah
they originally wanted to make
the first uncharted game remake that
from the ground up right in the first
uncharted game
imagine that remade in the uncharted 4
engine that would be gorgeous
too much work right that was the sp
that's kind of what came out of this is
that oh that's too much work let's do
something that's going to require less
work so immediately you know
the the the verbage and the language
around it is indicative of less work
in order to make money which feels like
a cash grab so again
it's one of those things those words
didn't come out of their mouths but this
is what happens when stuff leaks right
and
neat that's another thing they get
naughty dog gotta show up
makes they always puts them in a bad
situation i feel sad
with part buddy it's my man henry
henry don't like what's been going on
yeah anytime something's supposed to go
down henry gonna leak
and henry need that tmz dollars oh
but that's i mean that's pretty much it
man it's not i'm gonna be honest i'm
looking at it and i was hoping for more
i'm not getting this at launch i'll wait
for it to come to the service because it
will come to the service at some point i
just played last of us again in 2020
right before part two
um i don't need to play it you know
again unless they come out and be like
yo they added exposition here they added
cut scenes here
did you see like the playstation
official twitter with the
thing that came out after the leaks to
kind of
well what did i probably did but what
did they specifically say no no it was
just more of like just
clearly i'll i'll talk about what it
would exactly but um no i hear what you
say yeah don't jump in like for me again
it's a no-go for me at
at launch i understand why they're doing
while they're doing it and it makes
sense from a financial standpoint and
what they're trying to do with this
property moving forward 100 makes sense
but i also can't argue with the hardcore
that's like
when we've seen other remakes and and
kind of the extra mile they've gone to
this does this feels undercooked for
that and i don't want to diminish the
work that's been done on it because
obviously it sat there for 10 minutes
telling us all the stuff they did under
the hood to make it a better game and i
appreciate that and respect that and i'm
you know i'm sure i'm going to notice
that when i play
but to just looking at it on the surface
and watching 10 minutes of gameplay of
it i'm like there's not much for you
that i'm going to notice moment to
moment that's really going to push me to
be like i have to play this day one
without you that's it
king do i go on because i had to take no
no no i'm already done oh okay i just
want to make sure i'm just adding a
little sprinkle a little salt
yeah this was a crazy week man this was
what i i'd never seen nothing like this
um so well let's do the timeline the
start of the week happened shout out to
special nick i believe
he was the one that at least the first
that i saw have the um
the footage of the game right and the
leaks
of the game in motion in game play
and you know
twitter responded in kind they were not
impressed you know it looked again the
footage that was shown right look kind
of washed out
obviously you know the compression in
hdr stuff is that's gonna be affected in
any type of twitter or you know
decompress but um i think one of the
standouts that i saw was that like you
know one of the people people were under
the impression that it when it gets
built from the ground up that they'll
have last of us too prone
that the the things that lasted to dodge
you know what i'm saying and then like
um
you know just just reworked ai like the
way they were saying and i think in one
of the clips the only thing i didn't
judge it even though twitter was going
in
i didn't judge it on the ground because
i'm like i'm gonna wait until the
official sony footage before i go crazy
say the graphics look whack right
the only thing that i did see
the the ai you know like your companion
ai they follow you
and what was expressed was that you know
when they shoot
now with the technology you're going to
have that you know they're going to be
smart they'll be taking routes and stuff
like that in that particular footage i
still see the ai doing kind of old
school last of us one stuff not aware so
i was like that was the only thing that
really bothered me everything else i'm
like you know what i'm waiting into the
thing because to be honest
this was something i had my heart on
like i was like yeah i'm probably gonna
pick this up you know what i'm saying
i'll be honest now
what's funny is it got so crazy on
social media
if you ask me
play st there's no way playstation just
put that out right after like to me that
was the we got to get in front of this
that is not our footage that's not how
the game look and they broke it down
they had the 10 minute joint the
graphics looked better i was like okay
and then in defense of playstation
we don't know when that footage was
taken in the in the bills you know what
i'm saying so league building right
now i'm not going to go crazy i'm just
going to look at gameplay stuff and see
what's going on so when i saw that just
like graphically it looked nice it
looked good the models look good you
know what i'm saying whatever whatever
now i get it
the last of us two gang is like fam
where's the prone where's the dodge you
know what i mean and the last of us two
fans a lot of people like yo that's 70
dollars ain't it you know what i'm
saying like that people people don't
feel
what was offered and they go down they
go into a whole thing they're doing the
4k they're doing the 60 doing the
dynamic feedback i mean they're haptic
feedback they're doing the vrr you know
what i'm saying but to addict's point
you know the multiplayer is a big a big
part of the game you know and that's not
there right so
look
me personally this is something i plan
on getting i'm just not getting it it's
a vrr shut up
i know you know this is something
does it feel it's worth 70 based on what
we've seen so far however i am not going
to knock someone if they like yo
i'm in because let's be real when it's
your joint that you love
you copping
you know like if it's the joy for you
and they come out and it's whatever but
brother i love that game i feel you
king loves that game i feel you i really
love last of us two more because of abby
yes
yeah i know i know no it's soft i i feel
y'all and i see i see a lot of people in
the playstation community like nah that
ain't it and i gotta respect it it's one
of those are they waking up
i
so far this year because i told you
remember
and sorry to jump and get your segments
it's just a call back to your king
i got to see the mess-ups in order to
say oh i see you guys they're slipping
and i said okay well it started with
gran turismo you know it started with
horizon
no
it was it was horizon then grantham is
wrong right yeah it was horizon
then it was gran turismo now here we go
again here we go
shout out
and it's like
this nefarious dude has always been at
the center
of all this controversy and i say it
every week i don't have a topic but i
just said
i leave it up to the gods estonia would
do something this week to allow me to
have something to talk about and
for a fan base to say
we this ain't it
and y'all have accepted a lot y'all yo
you dudes have grown a lot of remakes of
a lot of remix and this we make right
here the kids is crazy the the the
remake this remake has broke the camel's
back
what was this one here's the thing and
add it girl you want to say something
before i go
are you good yeah um
sorry
we're having like a little family thing
so there's nowhere else for uh for my
girlfriend to go while we do the podcast
they're behind the green screens
but it's just like look like i'm not
saying don't buy this go out there and
buy it if you want to
all i'm saying is just like it's just
crazy the amount of scoping that some of
these companies do they get away with
everything everything
is sorry
but it does feel like
some other companies can't get away with
what other companies do all the time
yeah i mean what we know listen is is
it's always all going to be on
reputation and delivering a good game
and the people who deliver good games in
their defense they they had a
masterpiece with the first one so
they're going to be allotted
more cachet
than another studio that's just
it's not fair it's not equal but that's
just how it goes but this to me is is
the thing and
you know there's some talk
about you know on the other side like yo
dudes is hating on naughty dog and they
always leaking
they join and then there's another thing
where it's like okay
i gotta be real and this is the part
where i do emphasize the people that's
like yo that's not it
is i look at a situation like gears one
ultimate remake
right
had everything rebuilt pretty much from
the ground up
okay 60 similar situation
multiplayer was brought over
right and then the price point was 40
dollars
so that's i think the the strongest
argument like why is the need for the 70
right but they think they want to pay
the 70 though right and here's the thing
sony knows
yes and this is why i got to give sony
credit
sony knows because the market and the
data what they have with their analytics
their base they know we're going to pay
say this and y'all going to do it
yeah so so
until until the base
fights back with their wallet it says no
but see the thing is when you have the
beggar right you you you have the
business it's a banger though this is oh
no
it's it's it's not even about having a
bank or anything it's about taking
advantage of people's passion and look
absolutely every industry sooner or
later like you're never go someone
that's passionate about something it's
like i'm not gonna just because
something like a jrpgs didn't come to
xbox doesn't mean i'm gonna wait for it
so obviously i'm going to go out there
get that and it's the same logic we're
here it's if you like last of us you
ain't waiting for this because of the
ten dollar pricing right and and that's
the key
we see pushback on social media but as
we know social media does not represent
the whole of the world yeah what happens
it doesn't retail so it doesn't but
social media can definitely influence
yes yes and to your point attic great
point
they ju
yo what's the leak half him then he's
like yo next day here you go here's 10
minutes yo yo that's how it look y'all
this so they they care
about their perception they care that
this thing is getting ready
to look like the bad guy right so
they're like yo though this is why this
is why yeah beauty you know the values
in the eye the beholder you know i'm
saying the market is going to dictate
whether or not this is a goal if it's a
goal expect more of this because in my
opinion
jim ryan saul said something that he
stole some bars for me now ready like
jim ryan to me when he jumped on one of
the key things he said that i caught
was like yo
the gaming console market is not enough
we make masterpieces we make
blockbusters right
we are not happy with the 10 million
that these things should sell more right
so what do you do
you remake the remake the remake right
right hold up damage to public
shut up then let's rewrite right soft
you got you got your man pedro pascal
hbo
last of us movie let's get the new
people who never played it because let's
say the movie pop i mean the joy pop now
you got a whole bunch of non-gamers
that's going to be like yo what's last
of us oh we got that new new right here
baby we got that dude no you don't say
they may not know about the factions and
all that whatever stuff like this they
just like yo i want to be pedro you know
they got the skids or whatever whatever
and that's the thing the key is going to
be the market will
the hardcore or the people who say yo
that ain't it be enough to stop
them
this this is the thing
and
we advocate for the hardcore dudes like
you i know this sounds like jokes and it
sounds like we're going at sony yeah
because we are basically um
but the problem is you don't hear enough
of the fan base saying i don't like this
practice now you heard a couple of dudes
saying it yeah and then four or five
dudes might not buy it but the new dudes
and i told you this is not about the
same users they don't like the same
people they want new people
right you know
jim wants the new stuff
you old he don't want you you know you
know the crazy thing
king they want the new people but they
want that new price point too yeah like
they they they want it all they want
every people is willing to pay that
though because they don't know any
better like like like uh
cog just said they don't know about
fractures they don't know fractures it
was supposed to come with it or whatever
the hell they don't know about the old
one in 86 they don't know about that so
what they do know is this is what i got
and if this show pops then this attaches
this to this and then you get this other
aspect of it this way
listen jim is is a huge strategist a
great strategist i honestly believe i
think he's a formidable for of fulfill i
think he's definitely what's needed but
the fan base you guys
really need to be a whole lot more vocal
and just call a spade a spade you do
this stuff with xboxes xbox with a ship
uh gears of war uh
ultimate edition whatever without the
multiplayer aspect of it which was a
huge part because people saying
fractions is a huge part
they would ship it without it you guys
would have rung them so bring these
you know what else i've seen king
when it comes to
playstation doing something that is not
favorable towards consumers we're
entitled but when it comes to xbox doing
something that's not good for consumers
that's constructive criticism no i
understand that point and look here's
the thing
it the world sadly ain't a fair bro
it's just what it is it's just listen if
in to their credit
if you make great games
you are afforded more social cachet than
someone else so even if the practice is
one to one
this is a banger and beloved by many so
many are not i'm not saying it's right
i'm just saying oh i'm not i'm not
saying you're saying this right but
regardless what they make they can make
literally gold on that screen i can
still spirit bomb these plebs you know
what it is you know what it is looking
at the popularity of this title in
particular right
and and the pedestal they put it on
it is safe to assume
that in 10 years
we get a ground-up remake of this so
that'll be four times already
well guaranteed guaranteed so
that's that's where you look at it and
you're like man like
how much are you how much blood are you
gonna seep from the stone like and it's
one of those things money man cake
that's the money man no no and then for
sure i mean
jim jim
jim is in the perfect position at the
perfect time because he realized that
playstation needed to expand right you
see what microsoft is doing it was like
okay
we have to be able to compete in some
way shape or form
you see it with the with the service
based games you see it with you know
acquiescing to the
to the
subscription service you see it in every
different avenue of the playstation
business
this is that right um
pc right at the end of the day
[Music]
and you want to get the double and the
thing is the pc version they don't want
to say it yet because they don't want to
say how close to the
the ps5 version it is
it could be a month after bro like
they don't they specifically don't want
to say when that pc version is coming
because it's coming much hotter than we
noticed
they waited to the uh to the last moment
after they showed stuff they're like
because i'm confident if those leaks
wouldn't happen they would have waited
another month or maybe even right there
to release before they showed us this oh
hell yeah they're like we're gonna we're
gonna put our best foot forward which is
the reimagined cutscenes we're gonna
make everything look nice we're gonna
show you the difference between the
clicker and this clicker but it's but
that game play though we're gonna show
we gonna show that right before the game
comes out
on one baby you gotta jump
out
show your best before from a business
perspective i don't begrudge them this
at all but it's just like you're
somebody who's played the game a couple
of times already you look at you're like
i'm not that's us
right that's us we are the hardcore oh
he don't care about us he don't care
about that like i mean this is not i
should say he don't care but this is
towards a market that is a way but what
kids call them the out of town dude
they're out of town
more out of town here's the thing i
don't
i don't i'm not on the step that the
hardcore can't get something done the
problem is
i'm just telling you there i am i doubt
them
no but the hardcore has done it plenty
of times the problem is we all have to
be on the same ship who's we can't be
split on something because when we all
green this is bull and it gets fixed i
agree with look at that i'm
look at the star wars battlefront the
the drm for 2013 when it comes to xbox
the the xbox live getting ready for
what's going on about xbox we talk about
them dude i'm gonna watch them i'm ready
i gave you stuff that's happened on the
playstation side the spider-man stuff
happened i don't remember that
of course
of course you know
it's just like you know what it is
i don't remember it because that's
something i get i care about and i paid
for it
and that's what they encountered
because it's more of people that don't
care and it's when they love they like
yeah that's nice what you talking about
you get
the problem is is the people buying
these games they're not casuals for the
most part they're just not that's the
reason that sony's having to jump
through all these hoops to expand their
market because there's not enough people
buying their this is the hope to bring
in the casual right when we talk about
the show we talk about bringing right
this is the hope to bring in the casual
because again if not you're not if you
if you're hardcore bought 10 million
copies of this game right
10 years ago and let's be real that's
not i don't want to be disrespectful but
go to sushima
so 10
and
let's be real they haven't been making a
remake and uh drake was in the box and
ps3 version and so in my opinion look
i'm gonna talk my talk
100
right that game that you holding to your
face completely destroys last week yeah
as far as this
sorry bro once again go play assassin's
creed yeah i just like i just like look
because this is my favorite swordies
right so um i just like that they
turning on the so-called champ i'm just
joking i'll be a message
it's a new champion
it goes and this is the thing right this
is also about trying to bring the last
of us back to where it was yes because
when you look at the last of us two
sales that 10 million don't look good
the sequel to one of the most revered
games of all time sold 10 million copies
because i just got the ninjas in the
building leaking our stuff
yeah i know right not because of that
why the game didn't sell well the game
the leaks didn't help
no no no no
you know why i didn't sell none of the
people aren't on twitter no no you
didn't sell because of the controversy
wrapped around in the enigmas
but here's the thing
that's the hardcore on twitter it's it
didn't sell the way last of us one has
because it hasn't had eight years of
being bundled with the platform either
this is true too they they did crafty
ways of selling it so you're trying to
say that uh naughty dogs is paper champs
i'm like they're not real i mean they're
not real champs they pay you could say
insomniac is really the dudes over there
yeah well i mean if if if you're gonna
take the look of it that way and they do
a lot they they fudge the numbers and
you know they change the weight classes
and they do espn type stuff like he's
the only quarterback with
touchdowns to come back
i'm gonna say this i i think that i
think for them to stay at the top
you know of sony studios their release
cadence has to improve when you have no
you have insomniac releases you know two
games
in five years or whatever the case may
be and it's not even
finished
no that's it that was it i was like it's
not even that you know only sony does
this everyone does this so when you have
these games it's so this absurd amount
of units nine times out of ten you do
enough research that that game was
bundled with like a different console
it's just the the the issue
with the basketball i just want people
to know who the champ
issue is
and i do feel like that that is a reason
oh we lost him we lost him oh he muted
he had to mute because of the kids you
know
i mean we we we burnt out this stuff
yeah we burnt this out we got this out
it's just the fact of the matter is i
don't believe you guys you're not going
to fight up for this title y'all just
say no
they're going to buy it it's going to be
yeah they i i'm a physical guy so i need
to have physical ed what i'm doing is
i'm going to go support the devs and go
go then go stick your face out
and this is the thing and i don't cry
about it either i don't care thank you
to this and this this is always going to
be the case we're gamers we i'm so
there's very few hills we're going gonna
die on when it comes to stuff that we
love in games period like there's very
few hills i'm gonna die and be like nah
i'm not messing with you i i'm not
messing with you at lunch but i'm buying
eventually
there's very and that that's the problem
is there's very few whole uh hills that
we're all going to individually die on
and there's almost none that we're all
going to die on so that's why the
hardcore can't get nothing done because
it takes all of us to do it now
obviously
hold on hold on i got to break
will try and comfort the guard he's
trying to come for the ninja go fight
out super chat cog and attic i gotta
call y'all out that over over glorified
assassin's creed japan was not even
close to the last of us part two get
goes to sheba is you be so affordable
with playstation production that's not
what the numbers say though that's not
what the numbers say that's not that's
not what what's going on
according according to those numbers uh
that and you keep in mind last it was
part two i don't even know if it was
bundled mm-hmm yeah so uh mergers they
got to catch up
it's not even that so you mean to tell
me dawn
that that little old ghost tsushima new
ip brand new one a company by a company
that wasn't making those type of games
before that they made it infamous
tonight infamous
you mean to tell me that they was able
to make a game that is selling
the amount the not exact amount
obviously almost the amount if not more
than probably one of those anticipated
sequels known to man paper chair new kid
came in black we getting a movie off
rent
listen you can't come for that you can't
come for just a car unless we sent you
that's it that's the thing i will say
this it is it is the assassin's creed
game that ubisoft does not
give us that's yet to give us yes but
it's
that that's because they say i've always
said it when it comes to forza and japan
and assassin's creed in japan that's the
oh numbers are way down hit the japan
switch
bro you got that win that story but
let's go
on time
we're dealing with this topic
notice we'll be talking about marvel
numbers
is open-ended this topic is really dead
because of the simple fact that these
dudes aren't going to fight anything
they're going to sit there and take it
and they've been taking it for years so
that's why these practices are being
shoved down their throats and they're
watching it happen and they can sit
there and they they die on a bunch of
hills a god of war is never going to pc
spider-man's never going to pc and if
this happens then i'm going to chuck
this out the window first of all
y'all going to die on this hill the
playstation's going to continue to gouge
all the sony and they're going to switch
over to a whole game as a service model
and it's going to be the same stuff that
y'all hated i don't like game pass
because it's a rental service well look
you got it on your box right now so
again it's get down and lay down and
sony knows that you lay on your belly oh
you know what you know what's what's
crazy if you look at it from this
perspective we're paying 60 for the
original uh last you got to take that
off
if you keep that on i'm turning into a
into a fox
yo there's foxes in our game let's lick
yo i can do the win and go to your
that's in the games right let's make
all right so you're paying sixty dollars
for the original last of us you're
paying uh sixty dollars for the last of
us ps4 and it might have been sixty or
fifty one of those drinks
it was forty times
then you're paying 70 for this remake
and then they're probably gonna hit you
with that twenty to forty dollars for
that factions multiplayer
and our multiplayer is free and our
multiplayer is better shout out to the
legends mode what y'all know about that
so so all the things i just said
all the things i just said
and you know what that means called that
means that you go buying that goes to
shiva don't buy this 70 dollar
rehashed remake go pick up that ghost of
sashima that original story true we did
charge 10 dollars though we didn't
charge 10 dollars for the haptics that's
cool
because guess what you're not paying
that ten dollars you're paying you're
paying the ps5 taxes on top sprinkles
you're paying the sprinkles if they
remake the remake i mean
cause you know that's what they're gonna
do and this goes back to your point
goes back to your cashier
sucker punch don't have that cash [ __ ]
try to get a bag i want them to win
listen do it do it twice maybe i'm
listening maybe do it three times
all right let's go let's go
talk to the bungee get out of your
contract and come to where somebody
values you
stop being disrespectful which would be
to play at legends mode it's 399 baby
free 99 all over the death row
[Music]
and i saw i saw people talking over and
over again
uh this was my topic not kings yeah
people were asking whose topic is this
kings like this was my topic kings is
that ps5 lawsuit i'm pretty sure i'm
voting for the juggler he was he he's
out here playing with you super chat
super chat i'm going for the juggler
hold on let me get this laughs there's a
lot of them i got you i got you hold on
a second let me let's copy paste this
last one so someone should give some
membership so i could see that working
man i got to see that working in that
chat someone's to give some memberships
man let's let's get that going
hold on one second
give membership
some memberships cargo do some backflips
in there
don't let me get the sword i got the
sword
for the love of god someone gift
membership don't get this man killed
we got dan lazzaro five dollar super
chat king like godzilla versus kong
every movie isn't goof king
i did like godzilla versus kong because
so
if if you didn't like godzilla versus
kong so what and guess how much i paid
for it nothing because i saw it on hbo
max and i saw it every day it was there
available in my games of service type of
situation
i'll take it
then we got sergeant there we go there
we go i just wanted to see what it
looked like shout out to k johnson oh
yeah i don't know we need context
context
what you just said you just wanted to
see what it looked like
see see see the difference between me
and you go i know who i am all right i
know
all right i wanted i wanted to see that
and he showed me that
so then why did you change the way you
said it just now
y'all
you can buy peppa pig twice
then we got mad dingo big stick i got
your backs off
five dollars
but this is out let's go
look at all that green in the chat
because of that because that gift man i
i like that man i like that okay john
we're gonna have to uh we're gonna have
to work something out man
how you doing lady
have a great weekend no doubt
man they go make dickens five dollars
for jack king's gaming takes on point
his movie takes
the bushes
m night shot of mine
you know what listen i know you like uh
what's that under the sea i know you
like that
under the scene i know that's that's one
of your favorite movies i got you i know
that's a little mermaid and my taste is
a little high brow for you
okay
then we got the
donut taco 10 super chat
i was saying 70 for a one to one remake
of demon souls with with only better
visuals and slight qol improvements was
bad but at least it was the only way to
play it on modern consoles the last of
us part one is down bad
yeah i
i can't see the demon soul slander that
demon souls otherwise it's locked on a
piece no i look like i do think that
look is this technically a remake i
guess like i would consider this like a
glorified remaster to be honest with you
i do feel like like the resident evil 2
3 like those feel more like a remake to
me and you know demon souls that feels
more like a remake uh look sure some
aspects of it wasn't changed i don't
think you have to change anything to be
a remake i just think that when you
compare them side by side sure it's
gonna look different but i don't think
the the difference is so drastic when
you put demon souls on the ps3 and you
put demon souls on the ps5 side by side
they're going to look two entirely
different games when you put resident
evil 2
and resident evil 2 on the ps on the new
gen consoles and on the old system
they're going to look drastically
different when you put final fantasy 7
remake and final fantasy 7 side by side
they look different but when you put
last of us besides those cut scenes and
you put them side by side you could tell
a difference but it's not drastic i'm
going to be around with you
there's some liberties being taken with
the word remake that's for sure
um
there you got slow-mo back slap two
dollar super chat no
sony should have charged ninety dollars
they would have paid yeah yeah i don't
disagree
then we got a rel member for eight
months shout out to you
they told us ratchet and clank rift
apart was only possible on the ps5 but
portal was doing it better on the ps3
y'all believe a remake of last of us
yeah yeah that's the portal does kind of
mm-hmm yeah
and we got zai you know this is the
uh you don't you don't think about it
until somebody brings up that what yeah
kind of
yeah
ssd
casares three dollar super chat
uh last of us one remake at most sixty
dollars with the 170 ad story king that
is for sure give me more exposition give
me something else
then we got splendiferous two dollar
super chat when attic while out he
brings the little kid out of me
[Laughter]
yeah then we got bruno ramos diaz with
the 54
i think this is from brazil i forgot
what it's called
54.90
i hate 70 usd for any video game is
absurd and i don't care about companies
profits i don't work there i will buy it
on a promotion as i did the ps4 version
that's true in respect
then we got donald taco 10 super chat
every ps game this gen has had a great
has had a caveat rift apart six hours
rift's overhyped uh uh horizon forbidden
west buggy bodied by elgin kings will
love it listen you're at therese book
seven mtx written online only
the last of us part one now so what's
the caveat with ragnarok well i mean
he's stupid
you've been ragged and rocked
rules
two dollars super chat uh i caught cogs
who are you calling uncharismatic
you cut the chance what was wrong with
that's right that one would follow an
uncharismatic
board yeah
[Laughter]
i'm still functioning
[Laughter]
my coronation
so we got our chinese five dollars if we
chat we should wait for the last of us
re-re-re-remake for the ps6 to get a
second job to buy an edition that will
cost a hundred and twenty dollars
only to play 6 was coming out oh here we
go
then we got donald taco five dollars
shadow of the colossus ps4 was a
one-to-one remake and it launched for
forty dollars as i said it was one to
one look drastically different but that
is that game then we got the last of us
part one has less work done to it cuts
content and charges thirty dollars more
yeah hold on
coming for the ghost he said congress
twelve people on legends chill how many
is on the last of us uh remake
factions right
okay thank you thank you moving on
don't come for the ghost okay actually
shutting down
charge when um i love you tony brown
who was in charge
when in charge of sony when shadow of
the colossus remake came out
i believe it was um sean layton uh-huh
moving on see that's why that's not
relevant
so the fact that the different
leaderships involved and somebody who's
one simple
sinking and the other ship is actually
staying afloat and doing great right now
purchasing different studios and stuff
like that is because of the direction of
the cast he understood the fan base
couldn't be wrong a little bit more yeah
i can get more money out of them but
giving them less and stop giving them
more sean was giving you more for less
now it's over the ride is over this is
what happens when you vote this way yeah
and he's not going sean layton's a
gaming dude like yeah this is going to
play
jim ryan don't care when he when you
hold a controller like this you know he
don't play no game
yeah he didn't like that
he said
no the next last of us gonna be called
all of them directors cut
all of them
all of them
gonna be like this for all of y'all that
want defend the
what the [ __ ] the party rere remakes
this fam you 250
wow
then we got captain chats 4.49 pounds
super chat or whatever
whatever four pound and 49 pence super
chat uh 70 pounds for a remake of a
master of a remaster is a no-no
especially right now in a cost-of-living
crisis what the f are sony's smoking
they're on another planet they smoke any
fans
well i mean come september we're gonna
find out we're going to find out then we
got yeah that's when it's coming
then we got ty casares 3 super chat just
wait next year it will be on ps
essential yes it will be
then we got big cloud gaming 5 super
chat i won't be buying last of us remake
on principle alone you're charging more
for significantly less no sir i still
love naughty dog but insomniac is number
one
[Music]
or something i'm telling you the other
dudes in the building
yeah then we got elemental po 10 super
chat the fact that sony would go with a
money-saving tactic to make the remake
of last of us for ps5 and charging 70
should be a no-no look it gives a war
remake even that game had the
multiplayer yeah that is true i know 40.
matt yeah matt all right then we got
matt tichbon seven dollar super chat
coming coming coming in late today two
hours in and we're still on the first
topic okay better settle in for a long
one happy day happy lord's day y'all
yeah
all i heard was bob wheat grinder
bye we brought it
up
do you think playstation is using their
goodwill cachet too early i think people
will start to turn on them eventually
what does the panel think
they're cashing out and they're getting
everybody while they go there
going out in a blaze of glory that's
what they're doing i don't know how long
we're going to be here but i'ma get your
phone you got baby
okay we gotta do the taco five dollar
triple check cognac i gotta call y'all
out okay yeah yeah right there
exactly
i'll cut that boy up already like come
on
no no no don't attack me right though he
that's my man but he was fooled he was
born
ghost of sushima didn't get leaked and
caused a massive stereo that caused
people not to buy it because they got
spoiled early the last of us part two is
the last 10 out of 10 sony game absolute
absolutely yes the numbers are equal it
is great i don't give a 10 out of 10 but
that's fine but i give it 11.
and this to be honest the spoilers were
unfair there's a lot that was unfair
that was unfair
to go look at it don't look at that
that's what you get for looking at stuff
the only 11 i'd ever give that game is
that game was 11 hours too long
it's kind of true
then we got okay johnson thank you so
much ma'am for gifting five iron lord
podcast memberships that's fantastic
thank you thank you beautiful
and we have hold on a second i know we
jumped a little bit let me run back
jump there like a few
things
all right we got tai cha cyrus three
dollars chap
don't don
don ghost of sushima multiplayer still
came out before factions
that is true i just wanna know what the
multiplayer account gonna look like when
they come out for the new joint sorry
let me stop
and shout out to hargy cheney and
whoever got this uh code in the chat
forza horizon 5 premium
salute
thank you
thank you
he's a forza fan yeah he always i think
i think he worked for the forza team i
don't know man i don't know
and once again heart gets to me with the
five dollar heart gate you don't need
the super chat man just put it in the
chat brother like you appreciate it but
you do have a point there college he
probably probably in some way shape or
form connected to forza he should be
given a lot of fours it comes up
got that playground connected
they sent him like a document that has
like a bunch of fours of five codes
we gotta talk about this uh this fable
then let's see what's going on over
there
once again
for those with game pass forza horizon
five premium add-ons bundles shout out
to you hargy and whoever got that code
in the chat shout out if you got that
code and thank him
and we got otaku once again 10 super
chat just to knock insomniac down a peg
they have yet to drop a 9 out of 10 game
in the last 10 years but they can put
out six hour eight out of tens quickly
they're not naughty dog or santa monica
i have to agree with them like look you
can
we can have the argument are they their
best studio because of the consistency
of putting out games on their platform
that are high quality yes but until you
can beat the quality because to me
they've never made a game on the on the
caliber like a god of war of the last of
us that's fine though but they got
spider-man bro they got spider-man
that's quick that's cute i get it i get
it but spider-man is going to outsell
them all
and i agree with you on that and i think
spider-man did a lot for playstation in
terms of that but you know i do feel
like people resonate more towards like
the god of wars on last of us is like
those are like national launch days like
i'm not saying that like spider-man
isn't that i think it's more of that in
the mcu than gaming i think the game is
good
and i think it it it pushes needles but
as far as like ragnarok i think that's a
different needle that's being used in a
different way like sure that that
spider-man probably it definitely pulls
more of a casual audience than than
something like god of war but as far as
like the people that we appeal to the
people we do podcasts for i think they
would gravitate more towards like a god
of war i think it depends now with the
second one i think with the first one
because we hadn't had spiderman in a
while and it had been bad for a bit
with they've proved themselves with
miles morales and the original
spider-man so i think fighter man 2 day
one is going to be something special and
i think marine they got to prove without
yeah
and how that's going to work and yeah
you know they got some stuff but it i i
like the augmented shot the door you
know i'm having fun naughty dog is
ridiculous they like
there's levels there's no doubt we can't
be
we're caught up we're good
cool
finally hopefully a quicker havoc than
the last um
discord y'all um connect your worlds
it's coming discord voice chat comes to
xbox consoles
for xbox insiders right now so basically
series series x and xbox one consoles
for streamlined audio experience and
then you'll be able to see who's in the
call connect you got to do a little
phone setup to connect your phone
initially to it and then you'll be able
to see it into your console to switch
between discord voice and xbox game chat
so you link that bad boy and uh yeah i
just want to bring this out to the round
table kind of a bit of a surprise you
know obviously we did hear about the
initial news with sony so a lot of
people were kind of taken back like okay
this is just something they weren't
expecting so i wanted to get your
thoughts addict were you surprised
discord
actually coming to xbox
no really
you know microsoft usually the person uh
pushing boundaries when it comes to you
know how we do things when it comes to
xbox live comes to you know game passes
description i think they pushed a lot of
boundaries there so how we communicate
obviously would be one of the the roads
that they can go down
i didn't obviously it surprised me
because i didn't expect it but
i won't say like i was surprised it was
more of like that makes sense i'm just
surprised it happened
do you think overall good move for them
to get involved yeah by far i'm so upset
i still don't have access to it either
like yeah
it's not that low i know i don't know
no doubt no doubt solve xbox with
discord what's your feelings with your
thoughts yeah i decided it's interesting
obviously that it came there first after
you know the announced sort of
partnership between them and playstation
you would think they would have
fast-tracked that on the playstation
platform but again microsoft's been
talking to them for a long time you know
they they tried and sort of failed to
purchase them or they wanted to purchase
them for right it was like 10 billion or
something like that like so solve it
does feel like when like
when microsoft does something to this
degree it's like voice
they always try to integrate it to the
console itself and it's like yeah i
think it's coming to playstation
but i do think it is coming to
playstation because i i feel like
if playstation doesn't see this if it's
not on the roadmap now and they see
something like this like
and they don't do it
that's an issue because at that point
one thing i've always respected
microsoft is their ability to be like we
know we bought skype and we've got a lot
of uses for skype and xbox live is one
of them
but the fans want discord and we're
going to do that like yeah they could
have easily be like yo if you want to
talk to xbox players buy an xbox
but they didn't they're like yo
[Music]
yo
that's definitely not me that ain't me
that's me i told you
i heard that yeah
they shoot it
definitely not me i was like hey bobby i
gotta fight see i didn't i didn't mute
myself because y'all were like before
you gotta hear anything
you know that dude that cried he was
like
that's why i stopped talking because i
felt like king was doing something
stupid
yeah i thought yeah i thought kid hit a
button or something i was like
a little kid
with a training house
and that's that's why someone said sony
crying wow
that's why i personally feel like you
know
i have to think fortnite and epic i got
to because i feel like
these foundation movements is because
cross-play is becoming more and more
accessible cross-playing cards
progression and to this day i'm team
epic if they would not have pushed sony
the way they did we wouldn't be having
these cross-play call of duty wouldn't
be cross-play destiny
and because of that
now since we have the cross-plane cross
progression we need more realistic ways
to communicate with other platforms the
discord is the common denominator
everywhere so it was the next evolution
of cross play is cross chat and the only
way you could do that is discord unless
everyone comes together it it
agrees to do some kind of like community
chat and i don't see everyone agreeing
to that so let's everyone reach out to a
third party which is discord and if you
want to talk to everyone going into a
game but like minecraft
i don't think you can do
any form of
audio chat in there uh you know there's
no there's no game chat
to my knowledge there might be one i
just didn't know about it and then you
look at battlefield when the new
battlefield came out
uh it wasn't in there you know uh game
chat was not there at launch and what's
the point in cross progression across uh
chat
if you don't have access to talk to
people actually so discord makes sense
no absolutely i would agree
king
where are we at with this discord
[Music]
[Laughter]
xbox announcement
shout out to phil dominus maximus really
especially
and
and odin satya
um
odin
odin is upon
us he sees all
he knows all mm-hmm and he goes forward
they tried to get discord they tried to
they tried to scoop bag them yeah scoop
back this coil was like nah man for
streets bro
like that man and went over to talk to
sony what's up we still going out on
thursday it's like yeah yeah we're still
going on thursday i got prior
commitments i can't be doing all that
solo
you know unless
i don't want to be booed up mm-hmm but
you know satan phil was like
so how about this um
this voice relationship
what is that how about we use your voice
on our tracks and stuff like that
dudes seem to like how you be whispering
people dancing
wow so how can we get you to have you
you know use your situations your
talents
so
it is
bill phil showed you there's more ways
to uh
skin a straight cat mm-hmm
but they had a did they have a
partnership
yeah that was the deal they had solved
with sodium
well i know sony has owns a stake in
them
in discord right now they went and put
money down and this is indicative of how
new sony moves they don't care what they
debuts do
[Laughter]
knew sony knew sony don't care what she
do he
lose sony's sugar daddy sony we got to
start looking at this
what is happening
is paying the bills
he come around once in a while but the
lights and stuff is sold
she's still moving
i'm sorry
discord
sony put down they don't they don't
respect sony money
i don't care what's going on somebody is
not putting respect on sony's money man
he paid brad
and he's still
still in the headlines next week with
microsoft wait wait are we saying that
they're tricking and they're not get it
all i'm saying what are we doing all i'm
saying is sometimes bill's got to get
paid and so these days
and they don't respect it they're just
not respecting the the sanctity it
hasn't even been a year yet
it's like soon as they give the bread
they turn around and say okay good clear
microsoft
and it's everybody it's not it is not
just one what is going on here it's just
a real sloppy pattern of situations that
happen
put an nda up but shut up for at least
him
start dating again
don't be public what you're dating
let it happen let people talk about it
let them whisper about it xbox is the
one that came out and said it though
xbox was like yo yeah cause xbox don't
care xbox do xbox said
you you put money down and we still win
yo
xbox is hugely petty and the wild thing
is this is gonna help the community
y'all try to block them
from with the bread you tried to block
y'all thought it was only one way to
skin a cat
he was like yeah we got money you know
we still part of the team we're over
there but we can still do we can still
talk
yo that's what this girl
[Laughter]
so now you're in love with this
situation yet again sony what is going
on we're gonna have to really question
what's going on over there
wow
didn't see this one coming from this
disguise
let's shut up
forget the discord buy anything's
necessary
this guy right here we got him baby we
got this car let's keep moving
he had a [ __ ] that's money too i mean
everything was 100 billion before
the the the thing is again the expected
integration of discord in the
playstation isn't too early next year so
we're looking at a six seven month head
start on the xbox platform it says early
it doesn't say it's january so it could
be even longer than that um so yeah it's
just one of those things where like xbox
is gonna have a head start there and
then if they fast track this to 1.0 and
everybody gets it on that's going to be
funny stuff like the insider stuff right
you know it's it's a select few people
the insider ring whatever
so but if that you know if it starts
working very quickly and they they iron
out the bugs it could come out to the
masses pretty quickly and i'm sure like
like king would would assume
phil wants to do that and get that out
there to the people so you know you
associate discord xbox but
end of the day
discord is that least cop is the common
nomination for everything everybody
wants discord whether it's on pc mobile
consoles discord all the ones that are
going to be kicking off with this
because everybody wants them on their
platform so
that's going to be the link
yeah i mean i'll jump in um
definitely a surprise to me did not see
this coming i assume that because they
had the partnership or the investment
stake that that would preclude xbox from
having any type of integration so when i
saw this i was like wow they still able
to get it even though i you know the
brand association i thought was going to
be with sony so that's the first part
i'm i'm gonna be honest i'm not a fan of
this integration as much but i know it's
the early stages so i'm going to wait
and see because it's like right now you
like the phone whatever whatever and
then i guess it's a one-time setup and
you're good to go so you haven't tried
it out yet i have tried it out i
connected it you know what i'm saying
but i personally i would like it native
right i want it like how the skype app
is now i will say this in sony's defense
that if the playstation version does
come and it's a dedicated app integrated
and you ain't got to use your phone
that's the l to the xbox version as far
as i'm sure that because i want that
level like remember when we had we
opened up skype there was an app on xbox
that allowed so if xbox live party chat
was acting stupid you could go to skype
like yo we over here skype y'all
you can do that on console so i would
like a discord app personally you know
what i'm saying so ultimately look at
the end of the day to king's point
yo
good move i don't know how i didn't know
how this was possible you don't say that
they would be able to bring it to xbox
um i think in a cross-play future this
is key you can't talk cross play and the
number one communication platform on pc
is discord and you can't really
integrate it nobody's using that game
chat let's be true
nobody using that it's very the bit rate
is bad quality is bad and you let's be
honest sometimes you just don't want to
play with randalls in that also right
you don't want to hear the randall so
you rather have your select your pc
dudes or whatever you know your
playstation dudes whatever yeah let's
let the um let them do that so yeah
surprise didn't see it coming that's
crazy i i thought from the beginning it
had to be across the board okay when you
talk about companies that have leverage
discord knows what it has right i don't
think it would ever have you know
sectioned itself off completely just on
sony and then pc because i mean they
they're shooting themselves in the foot
at that point they know that everybody
wants them so i think in in negotiations
the that conversation happened
they they knew they for them to leverage
discord across the board from the
beginning they weren't going to allow
sony i'm sure somebody probably tried to
like hey man what's it going to take to
get you on here and that's it
but it's like i don't know i was just
surprised that they
i didn't think they'd do the integration
to be honest i didn't i was surprised
but i was like oh wow they're going to
still do xbox integration i thought
again you know that with playstation
they would have
some form of exclusivity with the
integration and that only them on
console will be able to do the discord
thing so i was like damn that's a major
blow to xbox so i was surprised but to
your point yeah maybe the the structure
of way discord works is not to isolate
xbox you know and other platforms out of
it and maybe that's why they don't want
to be acquired
they were getting the streets they would
for the streets they would lose hell of
money if they did that so it doesn't
make a lot of sense yeah no doubt no
they didn't lose a bunch
it was like 80 billion dollars but um
hey whatever it was
we're still here though
we're still outside the back the bag's
still available if you want them no no
we don't want that no more now we
already got your voice we already came
we got what we came forward
out of this dude why buy the cow oh here
we go exactly
i'm drinking milk right now and i'm
putting strawberry in it it's just wow
let's draw very quick we all we all
talking now look at us we all have in
the comments but i will say if
playstation get an integrated app that's
a w that's it they paid for it
[Laughter]
they actually ponied up
moving on
let me see we don't have that many we'll
scroll down
[Music]
and we got uh dorian gray
can we five dollars a project can we
stop with the insomniac they made a
spider-man game and half a game about
furries
we need a new infamous a killzone
playstation i'm an xbox guy by the way
yeah i mean killzone would have to go a
completely different direction and
infamous they got they got spiderman and
they got wolverine they're not gonna
make a superhero game what about
resistance i want to resist i want
resistance more than killzone give me
that resistance then we got ty casares
three dollar super chat sounds like saab
is part of the new fallout game
it sounds like people were heading for
the hills
into their shelters
then we got heated heavy 505 member for
26 months thank you so much
phil said oh discord got all the
playstation players ears let's get their
ears damn they need
hold on a second then we got a couple to
jump down
nope we got one more
yeah we got uh kool-aid 117 20.
don't get to see y'all live anymore
because of the work life but just wanted
to let y'all know that this is the best
podcast out thank you bless
and i appreciate you guys thanks for
that advanced gg
checking i know what to do
i got one thing to thank you kool-aid
that you
are the real goat for this
notice he said the best podcast not the
best xbox podcast the best appreciation
topics
some others don't do that you know i
mean listen when other people have
topics of of note
then we go
you always choose the playstation talks
i will always choose the playstation
topics because people are not
highlighting their faults and i'm i'm
i'm the mirror in the gym
hold up hold up hold up just to be fair
there's a lot of anti-xbox hardcore anti
that only talk about xbox in our
playstation as they probably and that's
their same mindset highlighting the
issues well we're good well i'm i live
in my world and my world is i'm the
dressing room mirror you don't look that
good people
i'm gonna talk
hold on a second we got
one more we got the don cj cjg
oh one pound 79 pence super chat
insomniac the goat now that's insomnic
cat oh
shots wow shots fired at the spider very
dad jokey there wow
crazy crazy i like that i like that was
you wearing crocs when you did it
probably probably
a lot of urinal energy there
strong urinal energy
we don't like that ridiculous
yeah we're caught up all right so next
up
ubisoft cancellations
what the hell is going on with ubisoft
so um
yeah and then on investor call earlier
this week or maybe a little earlier than
that um
it was announced that uh ubisoft was
delaying the avatar game the first
person uh avatar game was supposed to
come out kind of side by side with the
new movie this uh this winter
so that's being pushed into
at the probably spring
um and then we had another a few other
cancellations so they canceled ghost
recon front line which was supposed to
be a sort of battle royale yeah uh
offshoot of ghost recon which
apparently early on was not received
very well because people just want a
kind of core ghost recon experience
instead of a battle royale type thing
um and then the last thing
be still my heart
splitness lvr was cancelled
um splenius ovr was kind of announced at
i believe at the same time they talked
about an assassin's creed vr game so
they specifically indicated splinter
cell vr is cancelled not assassin's
creed vr so maybe that's still in the
works um
so this is it of itself games get
canceled all the time oftentimes we
don't even hear about them you know now
that you know we have access to these
investor calls we get to hear about this
stuff and speculate but in in past times
we may not have even heard about ghost
recon front line again
and and it just kind of disappeared to
the ether
but what i want to ask you guys is it
just seems like looking at this right
and we're kind of looking at the
struggles of ubisoft and sort of
how they've been evolving their identity
to sort of fit into this service game
type stuff
what do you think is happening with them
and do you think they're they kind of
lost the step again we were supposed to
hear we were supposed to apparently as
part of all of this there were other
leaks that came out that indicated some
delays um and kind of gave us a little
bit of an indication of where they were
going with with the assassin's creed
franchise um the skull and bone stuff
right
so there was supposedly supposed to be
an assassin's creed game that came out
at the end of this year that is now
pushed to next year
and i'm assuming we still get an
announcement a sort of a reveal of what
this assassin's creed infinite or
infinity thing is um this sort of
platform-based sort of game that is
supposed to be assassin's creed and all
types of different sort of time periods
and stuff like that so what do you guys
think i don't ub is not looking at the
start of uh kind of in the middle of the
ps4
xbox one generation i'm like ubi's
really hitting it man like at the start
they had black flag cross gen
you know they had their issues with sort
of um with unity and kind of getting the
new engine under wraps and stuff like
that and they had this sort of
renaissance with origins and stuff like
that but it kind of does feel like they
lost their way a little bit and they're
trying to chase this bag and create
games that are going to generate money
for them but in the process they're
taking their sort of big franchises
they've been known for these big sort of
expansive game worlds and stuff like
that and trying to turn them into money
makers right
and it kind of feels like the brunt of
that weight is kind of falling on
assassin's creed they're really counting
on assassin's creed to sort of be that
driving force but at the same time
changing what it is
what it means to be an assassin's creed
game so do you guys think i'm bugging is
this something you guys are seeing and
it does this uh
does this potentially leave them
open for
perhaps uh you know entanglements with
entanglements with perhaps xbox or
somebody else
what's your thoughts on this ubisoft
game cancellations and all this man
unfortunately uh i'm not have to uh in
the show um
so say windows is about to update you
stop it yeah
because uh
i've been able to use the the little
stream deck to because i had certain key
binds on the stream deck for when i was
uh doing something on another project
yeah but i don't have a way to stop it
from updating windows because i don't
have a keyboard of mine so it's like yo
we updating fans
it's literally it
it's literally not if you get bumped up
it's cool uh
but you know just in case i get uh
yeah uh booted out appreciate her for
coming through it was it was a good show
uh it comes down to us like you be
talking to ubisoft things saying nothing
to do about it um you know i like i said
last topic go on twitter uh respectively
disagree with them don't go see here's
the thing when you go out there and you
be left and you die disrespectful stuff
you're just in the ether at that point
they're gonna mute you they're gonna
block you you're never gonna get nowhere
go on twitter tag everyone on ubisoft
you could think of don't even at the
studio
everybody at ubisoft you could think of
even with that studio doing everything
right
tag them because they owned by ubisoft
and they're going to complain to them
just as much as they're going to
complain to everyone else uh get get the
get the word across you don't want that
happening it is what it is um oh no now
it's it's updating
my screens are black now all right uh
but i i appreciate uh everybody for
coming through that it's it's literally
i'm sorry
i'm sorry that you you see
yeah i'm gonna let you know this is the
um
[Laughter]
you know um
you know where you're at with this what
this dudes are these game cancellations
and stuff
i don't care about none of them um
none of them moved my needle uh
used off is like addiction is really
doing what ubisoft is supposed to do but
they they probably was cutting off a lot
of projects that was dead weight that
weren't going anywhere and they didn't
have any real direction on it and right
now what they're trying to do is show up
their games and service because remember
they also have a service based uh
subscription model as well
uh i still feel that they're going to be
purchased by microsoft at some point in
time
um
but we're still talking about uplay uh
coming to these platforms so again at
the same time
if it doesn't make money it doesn't make
sense and these companies are in the
business of making money and if a
project is stalled at some point in time
they're just going in there and they're
just removing it until they can get to
something else i saw a lot of people
like yo i want um splint to sell i don't
want this and
okay um
you you can want any everything in the
world uh
the metrics don't speak to it from the
company's standpoint so they're not
going to fund the project
and that's not going to happen so
again um
it's it's whatever to be honest with you
uh them
cutting off projects that they didn't
see any potential of growth in
yeah i'll jump in i i didn't didn't go
too too crazy with this one i just felt
like you know with ubisoft
i don't know man
i think they was like this at one point
for me like they was them dudes but it's
like
at some point they just peaked and then
we started to get kind of a formula
and then once i got the formula look
you know the thing i'll give them credit
though like a lot of the stuff that they
was canceling i felt was them trying to
catch a wave with certain things like
the ghost recon battle i mean actually
didn't look bad to me but if they say it
internally that you know it didn't
really test well or whatever and i know
a lot of people that love that series
want a dedicated grocery car game they
didn't like the force whatever whatever
i get that you know um obviously the
assassin's creed is still i mean even
though i've moved away from it i know
that's still there moneymaker that's
still the big one for them and people
still like the franchise where it's at
shout out to the cars myself
but you know look they're cancelling
stuff they're streamlining things
they're in a transitionary period as
well to me they have to figure this
thing out they've got a lot of things
that they need to make decisions on and
i think what is they doing on division
battle royale now i heard the division
the heartland thing i don't know that
it's battle i know it's a game as a
service in in a different it's free to
play right so it's not going to be a
paid game
um like division one and two
um so we're going to see where they take
that um
but it just feels like you know what it
is
they still haven't been able to find
that that bag
game as a service the way the modern
ones are thriving right like a fortnight
or or a war zone right they haven't
found that because siege siege isn't
that siege has a dedicated fan base
that's very sort of is very esports
oriented but it isn't making money hand
over fist right it's going well for them
i don't know you're right about the
financials i don't know about the
financials of siege but i know
you know when they first started off
that that game you know wasn't what it
is
yeah
movement like it's but you're right
esports they want a money maker in the
vein yeah and for honor again it has a
very dedicated fan base i don't know how
if they've recently updated it seemed
kind of quiet on the for honor front
right
and now that is on current gen consoles
and it looks fantastic on the series snx
yeah so it's but it's still it's not the
fortnight right it's not the war zone
it's going to be there exactly but
ubisoft doesn't i i don't really feel
like they they want that they're going
to keep searching for that whatever what
the hell were the other games that they
announced that they kind of eliminated
very quickly there were two games that
they announced that kind of
mostly vr stuff exactly no this wasn't
vr it was they were trying to hit that
battle royale thing and it just didn't
work then it had the other one that's
like really colorful oh i know what
you're talking about yeah yeah yeah i
know i forgot the name of it i know yeah
i remember yeah right it's like they
were trying to do the uh the overwatch
slash you know battle royale thing with
the fortnight and it's just it seems
like they're trying to find their
footing there right and in the absence
of finding that footing with a new
franchise or maybe with a lesser
franchise it feels like the weights
going assassin's creed yeah and
that's what scares me because that's the
assassin's creed really the only thing i
still care about there until they give
me splinter cell back so i don't know
man i i really do think
if this stuff they're working towards
now does not pan out
i think they're they will be in a
position to sort of be like hey somebody
somebody grab this up and see what they
could do with it you know and i think
you know when you look well
cog and i'll talk about that later but
there are
there are deficiencies in the xbox
portfolio that could be addressed by
ubisoft portfolio so we'll see
um i'm gonna be honest i'm gonna push
back some like i know king don't like
what i
i don't think they hide like that no
more like no they're not there anymore
they're trying to figure it out they're
not there anymore right and i'm like now
to your point this is where microsoft
gets these food in
i give you that microsoft like to come
when you can't pay the rent
so i i heard you know i heard that light
building
and sony's in this live service bag you
know trying to move
we'll see there's a lot though that's a
lot to manage though like a ton of
students a lot of the studios all over
the place
so
the fact that they excuse me
picking up this high profile acquisition
lawyer uh going forward um you know the
antitrust lawyer
this this
it's highly possible that they're
looking at a lot of these companies that
are in line with what they're trying to
do
and ubisoft fits the bill
um i think ea fits the bill
because as far as games of service and
having a portfolio of games like you
know what makes more sense to me with
sony purchasing anybody not ubisoft it
makes more sense for them to purchase ea
and the reason why i say that ea has a
ton of multiplayer stuff that will
fix their deficiencies immediately like
right off the rip
and that will change the whole narrative
expensive tony doesn't have multiplayer
games and for their service
and then they wouldn't probably lock ea
off anyway you know
like the same way with uh
microsoft um
go do your thing uh but this stuff is
available on our platform because now
we're talking about the platform things
but
um ubisoft i think they're more aligned
with microsoft and i think their
conversations with microsoft is going to
lend to that purchase i think i just
think that you know
yeah we got to see what's going on
we'll find out because i think that i
think i don't know if it's announced or
the speculation there will be a ubisoft
forward
uh
kind of indicating the future unless
they pushed it back because they there's
no assassin's creed game this year is
it's been pushed back um unless they
still want to talk about what infinity
is um or whatever else they have in the
pipeline again uh is does beyond good
and evil even exist anymore right
things like that so they have things to
talk about if those things are still in
the works
so there has been speculation there will
be some sort of uh showcase later this
year but we'll see yeah they
they're one to watch to see what happens
because of the cancellation potential
consolidation and look there's you know
we this is lord acquisition season
people are looking so it'll be
interesting if if one of the majors do
come with the cape on you know what i'm
saying that they pulled through but yeah
we got to watch it but that's all i got
on it we got super chat before we get to
the last one yeah we got a couple real
quick hold on a second
we got to do
let me roll down
[Music]
we got lord metroid okay hold on a
second no no we got rel
throw ubisoft into the bushes and they
will sell
them straight in the bushes okay
then we got lord metroid five dollar
super chat they won't cancel metro uh
mario rabbids sparks of hope that bag
will be heavy as hell as usual nintendo
brings the cash and this is just a
partnership now that's a good one that
they did recently i felt i was surprised
that did really well for them that's a
that's a good game that's a really good
game yeah i know and the second one is
looking like they really addressed the
end whatever issues people had so that's
coming out this year so i'm surprised
nintendo will work more with them more
i mean that's true i mean we'll see yeah
uh let me see
hold on we gotta
okay we have donald taco five dollars
super chat ubisoft gonna be fine when
game of the year mario rabbids two sells
30 million copies and makes one billion
they can cancel all other games and just
keep making those
okay over everything ring okay
potentially ragnarok okay all right you
got that rabbits out there okay yeah oh
shout out to chad cause yeah it was x
defiant was the colorful shooter there
yes
yeah another bastardization of sam
fisher
oh let me see that we have necromancer
zelo five dollars super chat let sony
have ubisoft just have ubisoft stay for
stay from microsoft's door yeah for the
streets baby everybody for the streets
um let's see what else we got we got
tech money two dollars money
how does sony beat ten cent slash net
ease in a bid
um
right it's
that means it's not just money right
there's other things involved that maybe
you know tencent net ease
morally for some people it's not going
to be
you know the bag has to be ridiculous
for you to throw the morals out the
window for some companies right
um i guess you know when you talk about
the bidding numbers it they just
nobody went without it had an outlandish
number there so
that's why
then we got donald taco 5 super chat
beyond good and evil 2 is still coming
and i think that'll be a good live
service game for them in 2020
yeah that's it
cool let's get this final one up out of
here and this is a king's topic
always giving us that fresh information
on the sony front
so we'll set him up um yeah shout out to
techradar.com
king eloquently found and brought to our
chat uh ps5 lawsuit claims sony
knowingly hid a major defect in the
console so basically there's uh sony's
facing a class action lawsuit regarding
a game crashing ps5 defect um the
plaintiff i won't say the person's name
from illinois after discovering the ps5
was prone to shutting down entirely
during gameplay court documentation
court documentation states that the
defect affects users abilities to play
video games and compromises the primary
function and overall usage of the ps5
and then they provided some evidence and
then you know more about the console
shutting off without warning during
gameplay but it says the most damaging
accusation made by the plaintiff is that
sony knowingly concealed the issue and
decided to sell ps5s regardless if found
guilty sony could be made to pay a fine
to cover the cost of these defects so um
yeah this is
king's topic um the other information is
that this is not the this is the latest
uh slaw suit against sony's far from the
first time a console manufacturer has
been taken to court over defect
previously nintendo has gone to court
over the joy-con drift that was remember
that um which causes nintendo switch
packing controllers to register music
movement when the analog sticks are not
being touched so yeah this is king you
wanted to bring this to our attention
what is your feeling on this potential
lawsuit
and i'm glad that they did bring up the
joy con drifts because a lot of dudes
tried to dismiss joycon drift and it was
a real thing and a lawsuit did pay out
um okay so let's get to this
juggling system
i don't think sony lied
i think you know cerny came out and told
you um
when power is needed in one way
that they're going to allocate power to
this side for that and when graphics is
needed this way they're going to
allocate it to that side so i think that
she was playing or he or she was playing
a graphically intensive game and and and
the xbox didn't know which way to go and
just shut off
and it saved them the fire maybe
it's the vrr back
now here we go maybe when you turn vrr
on the box it just puts it in a hyper
mode that you know it can't keep up and
it only got five minutes of energy and
you know they the the person went past
the five minutes
you can't put turbo in everything you
know
we saw a knight rider and knight rider
only used turbo when it was absolutely
necessary so you can't go in there turbo
with your playstation 5s all the time
because they will shut down kit shut
down every time he used turbo for too
long
he had to sit at the side of the road he
had everybody michael i don't think i
could do turbo right now you have to
recharge the boost
charge
i gotta give it a a jump like they gotta
kick i think the playstation
come
[Music]
shut down i think they need to have that
inside the box i think all new
playstations coming
next year
will have an automatic shutoff switch
but it will tell you first that you're
playing too hard you're playing too hard
tommy
you're in beast mode for too long
i got much to add to this oh i did see
the the article i did take a look at the
lawsuit or whatever and um yeah i mean
it's going to be interesting to see if
it's it's a settle if they could
actually prove without shadow death i
already tagged myself in it i already
talked to
don't act like you didn't get your check
the last time sony did a payout
you jumping in for your twenty dollars
kids yeah i gotta get my come up
it's ridiculous look we'll see the kids
they gotta prove without a shadow of a
doubt that sony could seal that like
that's gonna be the thing if they they
could prove we knew they concealed it
but i see this is the part where i don't
think that that is going to fly there
because mark told you when he came out
it was an unstable box
that is a juggling machine
he did say that it is
so we all know
if
listen everybody know here that we need
a current stream when it comes to our
electronics
nobody in this room no none of us 600
people here
are ever want a fluctuating current in
any of our electronics let's don't lie
like you don't want your tv all you tcl
holders out there
you do not want to fluctuate in that
television nobody here want a light bulb
in the background that's supposed to be
a steady light strobing they don't want
this
and your playstation is strobing right
now so it's an unstable body
[Music]
the playstation is up to new shenanigans
like
we're finding out that it's you it don't
like the game that you playing you're
playing too hard
uh
vrr we found out that if you leave it on
and burn your tv
and then we found out early on that the
playstation run a little bit too hot
all this stuff is surrounded around this
little box this 500 box it's very
concerning
it's burning your television he's
running around too hot like nobody would
ever stay you wouldn't stand for no
product in your house doing this
if you got a
hairdryer
you're fighting the good fight for the
people okay
if your hair dryer burn your head oh you
gonna keep their heads right in the
house
so are you urging what are you urging
the the consumers the community to do
sir that's what i want part of this
lawsuit
make sure
your voice is heard let them let them
make a stable box let them come on this
thing you try to gather up support to
support this lawsuit oh okay
this current playstation is out of
control
he's doing things like it's a wide
spread problem you know why because this
but you would not it's a gamble every
time you turn it on why are you playing
russian roulette with your playstation
fives this is this i don't understand it
and this is
is that a point right now it's not an
american concern because this this seems
like a cult because nobody sees the red
flags
and nobody's acknowledging this
would you give so you speak it up
this is a problem
this unstable box need to be controlled
and this is the only way
finally somebody stood up and said you
know what
so you with the plaintiff right here
he's being bold he's going above and
beyond okay
this is it because they was playing
ratchet and click
and and they they didn't rip the part
they did it and then the tv shut off
and it was still there but the machine
was hot this is a problem this is an
absolute
crap
this is this is what we do okay look
king what's everybody to get behind the
lawsuit it was actually it was actually
a woman it was a christina sorry that's
true
yes salute to her i support you i stand
with you christina
ten toes now
clearly king just wants to get behind
this we gotta stop these rogue plays
[Music]
though i will say this though like these
these sort of uh these mass sort of
lawsuits
they fight they have a way of gaining
not that not that they're actually
credible but it is one of those things
about you know like the
you know the the sort of
the sort of avalanche effect of this
right like all of a sudden
you get and it's like you said cod
it's just a matter of them
being able to prove beyond the shadow
right but i could feel that did they
conceal that
that would be hard to do just because
like it you know from the very beginning
people have had issues with their
playstations like any console whatever
that's all been documented right and
according to you know
to sort of uh
warranty stuff whatever if if this
happens when you're in warranty and if
you bought an extended warranty they're
going to handle it
you know why i'm laughing because that's
cat when it was the red one
so this is payback for the red ring
you want to be on the front line with
all the technical issues
the sega for microsoft division now is
for 360. that they have a widespread
issue that we got to let the world know
about king has to let the world no no
but nobody told me to wrap my
playstation up like e.t
do not wrap it up like e.t they told you
do not hit that vrr button they told you
but now it now
it's it's shutting off now
this is this is the problem is is a
barrier of fun it's a barrier to my fun
right now why is the playstation a
barrier to my phone i thought it was
supposed to be a corridor to excitement
and new experience you know this door is
locked like sometimes when they get too
hot they kick me out and they tell me
could you imagine you you tearing it up
in the rucker and they tell you get out
the court
get off the court
wait a second i'm about to drop 45.
that's
shout out to being an actual credible
website though yeah actually
i was shocked that's right i was shocked
it wasn't
calm
you know what i said you know what i'm
saying
i heard i heard about doc
so what i'm saying is dot com the
kickball about playstation news what
happened
floridaman.com
what was the other dude the ex-media
dude that used to lie about all the
stuff anyway
he's he's the listener man he's our
reporter williams
he was like yeah yeah we i was under
fire
every week i'm gonna be on your head
cause every week is something new next
week
we're gonna find out next week let's go
what's up what's dual since doing this
you're gonna find out that the dual
sensors giving people tunnel
people thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
this last topic is a nothing burger
everyone's computer does the same thing
so should we sue pc manufacturers that's
right everybody go out there and sue
alienware put your pc together the way
you did you made an unstable box
but if i brought my eye by power and it
be acting right i'm taking it back so
you can sit there and suffer in silence
this is a something
[Laughter]
[Music]
the ps5 needs a nitrogen tank inside
it'll fit
that disrespectful
then we got gabriel by choice five
dollar super chat king everyone under 40
is going knight rider kit what the hell
you talking about here
you know what google it
then we got bad dingo big thicket
super chat can someone ask chris hart to
comment on this i thought the magical
ssd would have prevented the overheating
i thought they believed the generation
wow let's see
[Music]
we got matthew ash five dollar super
chat gotta send the lords my cut from
the class action lawsuit
that's what dudes want that twenty
dollars
ps5 is going sentient and becoming alexa
b
baby
[Music]
learn how
everybody in the chat all that good
stuff yeah man another one in the books
hopefully addicts in the windows
updating the ubisoft strike could be
over for him and he'll be back but sub
uh where can the fine people find you
what you got going on sir
you know
we got a problem
all right
new io people with the recent
controversy regarding the last of us one
remake leaks and price point which
opinion do you align with the most the
choices are a
the market dictates the value of the
game gamers should be allowed to be
excited for a remake slash remaster
without being chastised it's their money
and their choice
choice b
game companies should be called out for
charging full price on a game remastered
multiple times in a short time frame the
changes are not substantial enough to
warrant said value or c i don't care
because when it's the game you love you
gonna bend the knee anyway shout out to
all those who wrapped the poll it will
be going up on lordsgaming.net
go check that out now
software the five people find what you
got going on sir
uh you know playing playing on my
platform of choice to steam
maybe maybe recording a little something
oh you know
something might because a little cooking
you know and that's it
but that's it thank you all for coming
through
yo flames stop threatening the pole talk
about sea will win again car are you
implying
that you are doctoring the pole the
editor of lords of gaming that's not
what you're implying right like flame we
just want to be clear
they can't click on the other two
options yeah let's watch it if i know
what he's doing shut up shout out to x
hawk and attack he said lawsuits will be
coming for that psvr ii cross-eyes
imagine yo
that's good the cataract edition the
cataract edition psp
was going
what's going on where can i find people
find you
you can find me at uh combat talk with
the king saturday with uh danny garcia
versus jose menovitas
uh next saturday um
that's going to be a good fight danny is
one of my favorite uh
fighters of this uh generation
yeah even though you know sometimes he
doesn't you know win all the times like
that's that's his biggest thing like he
gets to the big dance and he doesn't get
a chance to win the big dance the big
names like he lost to sean porter he
lost to keith's third and lost arrows
yeah yeah and um i just think danny
needs to drop his pops and get a a real
trainer
in the corner but that's not going to
happen because this pop's got him to the
space so
should be a good fight um a very good
fight because um jose benavidez is david
benovita's brother
and um he's a really good dude so this
is a measuring stick for danny garcia
because uh crawford uh last the last
fight that uh jose had of a top name was
uh bud crawford
and that was a good fight so we want to
see what uh
danny does with jose to see if uh is a
measure of stick for him to fight bud or
whatever
down the line um other than that you can
catch me on twitter you can catch me on
xbox king david otw and whenever my
playstation do turn on and this lawsuit
definitely uh is enacted as xbox 360
level one over there now
it is something concerning because i've
been trying to reach their customer
service forever and then they gave me a
number to call and they gave me a text
line to call none of that stuff actually
does work to be honest with you so if
anybody that does have the information
that can lead me in the proper direction
that i can get this playstation turned
on so i could partake in the non-fun too
yeah because apparently they ain't
having no fun because they're always on
twitter
hit me up so we can talk no
we're gonna break protocols off with
that super chat
akw five five super chat didn't the
return on dev say that the playstation 5
shuts down when you play it and then
sony bought them
yeah
because your wife can't testify you when
when you testify on you when that you're
married when she's your girlfriend she
can testify but when y'all married no so
that was a silence very quick marry for
silence so here's the ring
the ring
and you didn't hear nothing more about
that
you're ridiculous they said it ain't our
game it's the box and that's when it got
married and dead house mark was born
okay that's they was brought out the
next day shut up
shut up with all that talking there to
those people that don't need to know our
business like that let's see
okay put a ring on it you already know
soon as everybody to chat you know and
say shout out the [ __ ] they put up
customer service numbers what's going on
i don't remember the chat sorry i said
yeah
you're ridiculous anyway everybody man
it pulled up a lot of fun hit that like
it to subscribe all that good stuff more
stuff coming a couple of guests coming
through should be fun we got some really
good things cooking salute to um the ass
desks falls devs and stuff like that
they actually show some support from
what we're doing with their coverage and
stuff like that so with the attic and
all that but yeah that's all i got i
want to get a chance to play that with
y'all paul yeah you got to and the
rocket you got to get that going on too
but look that's all yeah well i got
everybody enjoy this sunday we up out of
here peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign